That's the question this guy's garyvee so that's a really good question
You got your prospective
Hates slow, do you rock? Of course, you hate it?
Right
Condition like it's it's just impossible like you can't fucking do shit
Fucking jump on board on my fucking tag
Sure, I
Believe that Sonic branding is about to take over culture and that things like the Intel
Audio clip and things like the Netflix sound and if you're from Jersey New York tri-state the PC Richards whistle
Right these things matter and I think as we go more audio over the next decade every brain in the world
Every person is gonna need their sonic branding their tateo tag
And so I'm again like I've done in my whole career setting the tone
I will not put out a fucking video ever again without a three-second tag
That's just the way it's going to be and every brand is gonna do it from Nike to Apple to everybody in the world
I can't wait to watch this when I have no hair and I'm old and I'm like that fucker was smart
I
Should bat. Yeah, I said no, but really
You rock yeah, you're getting smarter hi anyone what are you doing you're Tyler
What does that mean I knew I run into you two um lights coming in the city
That's exactly right see there
Huh, you know
Please get in a car, okay
Time over everything we don't drink I don't even drink water, but you need to hydrate. No, I don't
Mean I was just talking I was just talking to Iran about how much I hate slow
You're more than welcome. I don't give a fucking fucking Jesus Christ stops you speeding over everything
I guess yes
Jewish even yesterday like everybody we're talking to the word organically puzzle
How do you spell Palatine yeah
D-roc you're like me you can't JC de L
Was do you rock right? I
You're just getting you know the best part about what scales me is I walk in with no con
Zero right, which is fine. Dad. I understand you and Lindsay and read about nineteen meetings, and I'm like
But let me break this whole thing right now. This is what you need to do
And by the way, I was trying to move off of the whole concept of BK doing content
But I sure your idea was so right that I had at least teased them with it because he really wants
Version of that but great job by our team. Our team is doing this right like ya know
I'm like wow
Like I'm impressed because the Twitter and the Instagram is native imagery like I'm proud like I don't even do it myself
I get lazy on Twitter
bang this
I
Need a lighter he's excited about the party tonight
Bad ice well, you got you gotta teach him
That's on you
We're part of the problem your partner was problem ty
Do you remember what I said to Justin you're talking to me now?
like that
I'm the nicest
Are you kidding Who am I I fucking eat shit for a living?
This was the song that actually got me off Ray's email cap Jake
With the concierge
Okay, never went again I jump in here eck. Please. Don't talk sports
If you want to talk girls being the best guy swags being good-looking and rap, that's cool
But never have sports come out of your mouth again
In sports with you my man you want it you want to go throw down on sports with me now
You know, what's so amazing, I'm gonna destroy his soul this is what the best one you would like to Roger buddy's the kid
I'm debating with right now
Wanted to be a professional rapper like haddock like was in a group called mad appeal like this is a real thing
I am going to take so many pictures with the hottest rappers in the world tonight
And I'm gonna set every one of them to him
The crush in his fucking 44 he's finished
Why can't he ever come back did he never never was come back? I'm gonna say who made it further than a rap game
He said I wanna throw buck he's had no fight I'm telling you you don't understand the kids I went to school with
Because no, I want to throw bows just want some you want to know about this kid. He's probably like four four
Four inches shorter than me, but 273 times taller and longer the street
Thanks, I
Understand so nothing too crazy no
How's my inbox
Is what about you and Alex seeing if anything hot it's coming in I like when you guys text the hot shit
Then asking people's names more often I like it. Yeah
This is like you guys actually probably understand the most
Meta nature of my whole message which is of course because I'm a good human speaker. Like I good intent for them
I'm not trying to like get you know, like
Swans thank you, sir. Yeah, that's awesome should definitely do that
Not as bad as in New York this feels great, that's right
Super Bowl swag
Fuck this Super Bowl, which I hate the fucking Patriots. I got an Atlanta stand up
You'll walk into there was right outside
If you want to do anything with this starter, I want it yeah the Jets won. Yeah, yeah
What about deception? I just
have word
And I love it
Being nice that guy with the big hair and like all looking. I just look over just a little smile. He's files back
It's like it's nice. It takes you fucking idiot influencers, you fucking idiots like like you
Dream of of having a life where you could do anything you want
when the reason that's
possible is because people admire your work or your content or what you look like or how you make them laugh or how you make
Them feel and then you go into the real world and they want to interact just a little something and you try to act cool
Like you're somebody fucking dick
Be nice
Kindness is the fucking foundation of actual success
Fuck you patreon
Of course hey listen to you all the time thank you. Thank you. What's your name? Noah Noah nice to meet you
Thanks, um, well great meeting you thanks Noah. Yeah. Appreciate it Noah just made this clip the best that was so better
It's such a great face for coast to coast pitch it's like from Coast like Lily Costa goes something the degree of like
Hey influence or stop being dicks
That was like super great in a carousel. Oh
The great Nick, come on such a pleasure Gary Gary such a pleasure. Thank you. I
Really appreciate it. How long you been?
So, you know good friend of mine thick, you know, uh, Sam benroubi, I know you still work here's ago because
I did a show with him on Sirius right here called whinin web and I did it with ya
Thank you
We're talking about me
You were talking to me when you said that I totally get fun to read. I do like shit. What do you mean?
You know what
this is let's talk about this is this is what I went and d-roc recall the footage right now when I went to fucking
Finland and they like and they fuckin flew and they're like you got to go shopping now
I'm like fuck you and I was like fuck it. I'll take this pink sweater. Eat it. Tyler find that fucking clip you rock. I
Want that hold it from Lindsay for me being confused
Literally the only time I stop for the last five years, look be careful when you walk into Tyler
So he loons one more time running completely pulling at you like my wardrobe tonight, thank you
I agree
It was not great, but it was not exposure
I actually got better
Did we lose Tyler
Sorry Lee trick I work with him. Is that right? Yeah banks is here. Is he here today?
I
Feel super awkward. I'm good the xblock. Yeah
Yeah, how are you
Good
Hey
Man I saw what you host a party this week tonight. You've been busy tonight. We're out well
That's that
Respect we're uh, we'll be up pretty late. I'll text you the details a bunch of the guys are coming through
How are you? You look good, man. Yeah, you look good. Good. I've been really good. You're gonna get to New York for any reason
Nashville is that so maybe for maybe for the draft. I'll come by
Yeah, I think I've got a speech there in I just booked two hours
How you enjoying it dude? You're just ready for the house. Hey
Pleasure to follow you. Thank you. Thank you. I appreciate that
We really need to have a problem dinner at some point
I'm sure you know at some point I'm gonna start getting the competitive niche to like whatever right?
So like that's what I want to be around
Just come like I'll build around dinner maybe tonight if you guys are up for being late I will Nick take care
Of course I don't mind at all
Stop decline it
I think it's still
There. Yeah, look at you. Yeah, this is what I this is what I which are doing is what I don't get at this
Love it take you
All right, what's that
Everybody, you know, you can't you keep building on your skills
You know, I feel it too. You know why it's really big cuz it's coming natural to me
It's such a huge key
Like I'm gonna start trying to talk to the camera more when I have thoughts such a huge key
Like I've always like people say hello and like I'm feeling more natural where I'm like, yeah, what's your name? What's your name contacts?
I just like it. It's just a nice thing to do
something
Scary good to see bro. Sup, man. How are you?
Area yeah, now you're feeling good. Now. You're feeling good about yourself God, but you still make it scratch my net
So get me that's why people have the fuzzy thing right? Hello, how are you good? How are you?
Horse whenever whatever I don't know where my yeah
I mean we've done we've gone this far like I understand how all of a sudden fucking it doesn't fucking work
That's gonna be very good and now dude. I know what I'm talking about
You're doing something we are to be rather cheerful
Something a hundred percent is your fault
Yes, of course, how are you talks thank you, what's your name Sergio Sergio? Hi
Got it. Awesome. Nice meeting you sir, Jeff
What's up, oh yeah, of course man. Thank you
I think he's got it
I appreciate that. Yeah, generous. Thank you. Thanks Nathan. Thank you, bro. I will. Thank you
Oh you guys you guys are set up properly hi
How are you? Good to see you? Yeah, I was trying to smile at you in the back. I saw
You guys well
Good. I'll see you guys tonight. Awesome
For sure, bro
Thanks, man, you're welcome good luck to your jets. Thank you brother pleasure
The giant for you preaching so I love the skins and and and eagles like hatred towards a giant giant
Thank you
How are you
Pleasure
Thank you for your podcast. Thank you. Thank you Junior. Thank you. Big quit. Thanks for similar to I appreciate that. Thank you
BB our music group you did the stuff with Dustin. Yes. I'm nurse my favorite. Hey, well, well, yeah good. Good pleasure. Of course
Thank you. It's good to see you
Yes, thank you
Gotta follow you you know, it made sense
In reality. I used to have a best myself. I
meanyes know more about my brand
I appreciate thank you bro pleasure to meet you. Yeah, it's gonna flip gotcha pleasure
Yeah, I want to go on air I want to work Steve : it's
Going really good brother great man yourself really good, man
Thought process
Whatever works for them. I know they're on schedule. I'm I can be moldable. You're good. I'm great. Is it live?
So I can bring you a lot of listening
Thank you. Of course, thank you insulin. Yeah, of course, of course who's got
Thank you brother real pleasure, yeah. Thanks for listening. Yes
Lindsey blow
Awesome
Where's green he should come come sail in a Scott Greenstein you got
Yes
I
Got green Senor nice to see you Ben Wow been a long time boy. They nailed the shit out of it. Thank you, brother
I appreciate that means a lot coming from you. No, no no
Somebody walked me through your office it was like
We were are you see process? No, no way you have San Francisco
I have in LA and San Francisco in the open door building. No. No, that's somebody else and then I saw something in LA
No was your stuff. Thank you
That's good, but does that mean he gets to fire me that was the first thing I think
It's great to see it reconnect a hundred percent, I mean you want to set it up
We're gonna wreck this by text. I give up a lot. I know I mean love to okay, it's great to see you again
Bye see ya Gratzer. Thank you. Wait to see you
a hundred percent
Yeah
I was a Belarusian really. Yeah, I was born in Belarus. I was born in the Soviet Union
but I came when I was I came when I was really young I
Have relatives in white fog. Yes, not far from where I grew up
They had the first day the first shop
I know it's super well the I know the actual Wyckoff stop, right because in 2001
Bobbleheads exploded and I went out and bought them in every shop right? I'm sorry
I literally walked into the white coffee shop right with my cousin's had a wine shop
Yeah
all of it all
Springfield so so ever yeah wine library pick yourself. Okay heart. I want to go hotshot. Holler. Okay heart
Oh
Pleasure with Pandora, so
Thank you, how are you
Real pleasure
I
sure do
Sure
I don't know about all that smells amazing
Thank you Congrats on your business. Thank you very much
Yeah, it's been really rap. I
Love this world. I love my podcast. I love being on radio. I love this hold
I'm a big audio guy because it's the medium for I mean it it's
The explosion of this media is gonna be incredible over the next decade, I think
100,000 for 20 years hasip consumption with the way technics, you know, it is radio dominating the 40s, you know
It's the same old shit cycles
Passim came over it's gonna be it's gonna be you're gonna cruise to the rest of your career within this ecosystem
It will happen
Hey Thomas like the huge fan here. Thank you
Andrew said
How are you MC? Nice to meet you?
MC technology
I
Really read it thank you, brother. I love other thing you do. Thanks and
That's the reason that I do
It's so important to make your community hundred percent that was a huge
Real thanks. Nice to UMC take you I
Think you should do something really cool where I make that point and then you'd like to do a whole like
We just repeating people's name
And just let the name repeat by
MC be super cool and I'm gonna clearly do it a lot in this area
So that's just like a cool like break for like 80
Yo
I'm doing extremely well
We don't stop we don't stop I'm in full like
When you go there, you know as an athlete like once you're in it
that's exactly right like actually 20 you just said that something I've been thinking about which is like
yeah, so is this a perpetuity like this is just like it's just like a tornado like
I've been really think about it. Like is there gonna be a moment where I reset? Like I think there will be
Inevitably I think the problem might be a moment where I'll be able to
I'll be so overwhelmed with an offer to buy it all and I'll be like that's right for me right now with my family and
Like, you know like but I don't know
Me as a human. No, but I'm talking about the machine on building not me as a human me as a human is like
I'm drinking coffee right now. No, I'm drinking coffee too and shilling dad. It's not about that
It's all you know, honestly, you know, what's crazy about that nothing
Gratitude, you know which way better than fucking adderall gratitude when you're really fucking like what I said at the end
Like were we not like a fucking what on Instagram? I live it. I'm thankful. I'm really thankful. I'm happy
I'm like, you know, I look around I watch like people have different kinds of life
This poor gentleman is dealing with the kind of mercies in a wheelchair like this shit there shit
You know their shit
So like I live like it not even every day every second
But you know why cuz I know I can get a phone call right now and be like your dad died
Could be that's what we know. That's how life actually works
You have to because let me tell you what happens next you. Don't worry about dumb shit
When when your life is that?
Yeah, and then you don't care about other people I
Remember guys guys guys you guys grow up fast. Fuck you like older already
With who?
Good for you guys. That's awesome. Thank you good for you
Have you guys been how did you guys I remember our meeting very very well the whole fucking crew
How did you guys take the feedback like what do you guys what what happened postgame that?
You guys did you guys hear me
Like I'm 18, I just I'm not going to college but it's a
Right being thoughtful patient
Sure is it's great to see you guys again
D-roc recall the content with these guys in it. I want everybody see how much you grow up in six month early older
It's fucking crazy
Hit me up anytime howdy guys
For Bainer, we're fucking about to hire up fuck load of people d-roc help me here
Take info. Like we're Pierce Lee great. We're yes, we're hiring like crazy like uncomfy
Wealthy 100%
Cool
It's great to see you guys again good to see you guys flourishing
Yes
Great guy and a fan of you right here with all these stars. He wants to be you
Thank you mark means I'm smart if you like to throw f-bombs around
Such a pleasure. Thank your right-hand woman that runs your a lot of your
I'm an orthodontist and she did a lecturer they working on it. What does she look like?
Claude filbert. Yeah, Yaba Dirac. Yes. She she's amazing
Yeah around culture and like yeah HR
All I believe this is all one big game of human behavior and everybody gets confused of what's actually going on
She put me on to you. I listen to you and I go to work
I appreciate what do you live Dallas Texas? Very nice. You guys just took fucking porzingis
I'm devastated Knicks made a trade yesterday with the Mavericks and treatments are the papers stated
That good for us. It's very good. Pretty good. Once again mark good ownership. Good ownership. Somebody. Yeah. Good ownership. Good ownership
Nice to meet you. I'm glad you said hello. Thank you up and likewise. Enjoy your weekend. Well
Yes, Alex Martha one introduce myself pleasure sports host millennial Canadian
yes doing a sport sports gambling men's lifestyle show at the Mandalay vary my
Idea, yeah. Thanks are my own sport show and good for challenger pro athlete super-useful, Matt Barnes
Wallets have found essence Ryan Clark. Anyways, I actually tried to hit up AJ because I was like, you know
I'm gonna boot on the ground guy. I've literally interviewed probably about 75 athletes on my own booting operator of ESPN
Love got my got myself a job. Pretty much create. You made it. Well made it happen for you made it happen
yes, but now I'm figuring out how to Double Down and
Anyways, I loved I love to do a quick interview with you, but if you don't want to it's all good
I'm not really like yeah
100 smart you actually
How its Monaco co-hosted a d gentleman show chillin with the Mogul the innovative Gary Vaynerchuk
Diehard sports guy here last week baby's knee I were
Terrible. I don't know if we can curse on your format. It's very good. I hate doing it
I will hate the fucking Patriots and some thick
I'm sick being here on some level though the full circle 19 years ago
Starting only only good because we could talk about spy hate and the cheating waves of that Empire over there
Alright, so the show online. It's all about being a gentleman. Yes. Is it a lifestyle tips a little sports camp?
Okay, so first off yes, you're a gentleman. You got a great to swag
Yes
that good funks way for the grain thank want to know first gentleman tip either do a
Millennial or any young gentleman out there in training like myself. What's we go to be a kind person?
fuck clothes
Be a kind person. That is the new alpha. I love it
So so the inside shows the outs because I just like Larry David on the top
Okay, so that actually is like a first when you have a beautiful face you can do anything as hairs
Just call it big. I know Jewish move
On its own good good. Alright, so we got the game big game. Yes, red start about pick them now
Okay, that's two and a half. Yep. You're a betting man. Wait where you put your check
I would think makes its gonna win all day long
I do really it devastates me to say that out loud, but it is what I think is gonna happen
All right wolf 1 1 4 if you were to score a touchdown the Super Bowl
Yes, what kind of celebration the answer you've given the people?
Well, since I'm not good at dancing, I would probably try to create something that I could trademark and build a business around
Okay, so I probably create some sort of new like man's signal and then trying to sell t-shirts the next day. That's my deal
I like it. Okay. All right last thing
Yes got our shoe shine is one of our men's lifestyle segments 94 year old Jim told us the shoes make the man
Yes, where your ranking shoes in your giddyup? I know you preached inside, but give me a little fashion tip for the show
well
When you're when you're when you're at a place where you are in a place where you have your own signature sneaker with k-swiss
So you get to humble brag on shows like this, so I wear my own shit. Fuck Jordan
There's no kicks. Check out the cherries, Omo, Louisiana, very pumped people. He doesn't need caffeine just like Zev
Let's go Dee gentlemen show appreciation. Thank you very much. Thank you for having me
Email Gary and garyun to help you. Okay, you're dying. I'm gonna help you help me help you
I
Appreciate that with some Twitter. Thank you so much
I will
Right here break it. Hey, Gary. Hey Mark Cates. My little son Aramis. Is that right? Yeah. Is he still there? Oh, yeah. Yeah
They're sure we'll see each other soon
Stop good to see you. You men good. Oh, well. Yeah what's going on just plugging away
And you got our skills connect shine
What up, brother? You need somebody comp there and shit on the Patriots?
I'm too happy to do it
Of course
Gorgeous appreciate your welcome. I cannot wait to see you at the National. I got a table. I'm like this
I'm gonna sell we got a home. We got a hookup before I'm okay
I'm personal tell me up anytime. Yeah
Good dude you email me? I'm getting together. All right, I like you. I like the genre anything you want. I mean it
All right, everything good. Yeah, I just ordered a box of the what's the next fuckin football shit that's coming up this week
It's coming up this week limited
You guys are fuckin making too much shit Jersey on Tracy Gary Vaynerchuk yes pleasure
Happy to do it
Tell me why are you here in Atlanta celebrate in the Super Bowl? Um, cuz I'm not celebrating because I hate the Patriots
There's no celebrating. I'm here doing business. I have vaynermedia at Vayner Sports. So I have business
you know, there's no celebrating going on here for
Like enormous Lee
I'm rooting for Sue and
Sue, I'm pushing for Sudha NT v12s career since it doesn't seem like he wants to ever fuckin retire
I don't know if you guys are beep in here or whatever. Maybe this year. Maybe definitely not. He already said it
He's literally playing 245. I already know and I have this weird feeling some
Some like dust-up of playing till 50. We'll probably get into his mind
I literally feel like this man's gonna play until I die at 150
Would you be able to tell me and obviously as a lot of hard work some talent, would you be able to give up everything?
Like this sugar the dairy, of course
You would be I've given up leisure to like build my professional career like shitters easy
Yeah. Yeah, I mean when you're with us, I think Alan look it's it's this I'm sure like you've written you know
Like we all know like if you love something like love something
Yeah, you're willing to give it up
like everybody here is giving up something that some of the aus loves right like
You know for me for me and different sugar might be like whoa, right, but for others, so the reality is when you're passionate
Giving up something for that passion actually comes natural to most people. I love your Instagram post
You have a lot of tips and motivation. What motivates you
Leaving a legacy
Trying to deliver on the fact that I was parented extremely well and there's almost like a almost like an underlining
Gratitude and guilt thing going on, you know
admiration, you know
I like when people come up to me and say thank you and it's not because I can throw a football straight
it's because I've said something that has helped them deal with a
Negative situation with a parent or built a business that has helped them get out of debt. So I'm eration
And yours and we'll an accessory got it
We're with or on with we're with whatever I got it, yeah
Hey guys Heather Catlin here with the one and only Garrity. Thanks so much and everyone's with Access Atlanta
All right
Going in three two one
Old school is out conference on time SMS coverage of Super Bowl 53
We're here with the one and only Gary Vee at the media center radio row on Friday Gary. What's up, bro?
Life is very good. Thanks for having me
Listen people take the sports stuff too serious
And I love the way you do your thing, and I try to do shit like that
A lot of people say that I'm like the Howard Stern of the bodybuilding slash sports communities
I don't know about that big shoes to fill but you got to have fun with this shit, right?
well
I take sports extremely Sports is actually the only place where I take things out of context like I'm hyper
emotional like I hate the Patriots with all my heart, but like I hate them more than I hate like
Warlords in Africa. I'm like I'm completely over the top which sports I'm very common business. I'm very common real life. I'm
Unemotional in every part of my life except sports. So, you know, I take it very seriously. I
Mean it's kind of a strange past couple of seasons with a lot of NFL taking some PR hit. Yes, stuff like that
So horse, how do you would tribute that with the with the hoopla and the gala and the dog and pony show?
That is Super Bowl week. I'm coming from the apex like the NFL is the religion of America
So coming a little bit down from that
It's still gonna be a lot of hoopla and passion and so this is America's sport
And the reality is it's got a long run in it, obviously
It's it's dealing with certain issues, which is are in my opinion appropriate on many levels
And I think it will navigate through it because at the end of the day
You know when you look at the AFC and NFC championship game, you know those moments those over times you're capturing America's
Imagination in a way that very few things do and one last question
2019. Yes. What are we looking forward from you?
That's a great question Vayner X
which is the holding company that has all my companies in will probably have one or two more companies and
I've got one little secret thing in the sports world that will drop this
Spring that. I'm extremely pumped about Zoe right here at the media center radio row with Gary Vee
Can you do a quick promo for me? Sure, just say this is Gary Vee and you're watching MS TV quick and simple
What's up, guys? It's Gary Vee and you're watching MS TV
Tyler
Yep
Thank you
The Wine Library, I love the Chanda nice to meet you
Thank You
Josie Josie
Sure, is that it? I love it
Fuck is right there. Like that's a lot. I'm like, oh shit. Yeah
Thank You Jay thank you. It's a pleasure to meet you
Please Please, thank you
Thank you
We're like I get so excited like during the meeting
I was just like all hi felt like when we were yeah or in general or army army gotta keep down good like our
So here's where rather where?
You already know our situation. Yep. We started like taking video much more. Seriously. It's been watching
Him Devonta Freeman, yeah, the real Tarzan like they become our clients because we took this up instead of
Landing versus sales. Yes. Everything comes to me. I don't go and get it. That's
Me too. That's what I'm trying to get a fucking generation to understand we say these three words
And and by the way like
Religion and college and like everything ports Brandon's life and everybody's intercourse
Everyone's trying to be short term money and short-term tactics which dilutes brand
When you extract money out of people's pockets, you might have gotten it. You're just not gonna get it again
I'm gonna have anybody's fucking money if I want it in perpetuity
Trying to bring value
You fucking put your head down close your fucking ears build
Unlimited brand and the world will come to you with more dollars than you ever fucking would have gotten if you fucking stole it
So it's humility and patience
If you fucking want a Lambo and if you want to buy a $15,000 table at Vayner Sports is party tonight
That's hard to do what I'm telling you. I keep reminding people
Listen to what I've been saying. I didn't do a shit until I was fucking forward like this is a like like, you know
Where do you go from here? It's fucking working for six months
Why don't you do it for six years and find out how much fucking leverage you have?
You're still gonna be fucking fuck. I would rip my fucking leg on tip. No, I know you're not
I'm just getting excited
I would literally rip my leg off to be your age in six years would literally be like fucking
Like fucking give me like, I mean it I you know
I'm really telling you like I'm telling you like you give me twenty six years old twenty four years old like
I'm like fuck it man. This leg is not worth 20 years
I'll give it to you like you're in such a great spot and the fact that you're starting look this is probably the thing
I'm most excited about with my legacy. I'm getting the kids young now
you guys are representing the first generation of me getting in early and
Actually getting people out
Before they would have went through the cliche path and now you have all the upside
I'm getting people who fucking realize they fucking dinner. They're 46. They gotta fuckin retrain themselves start over you're in it now
So what do I think you go from there?
You know
Look, it's okay to make a couple bucks along the way but this of course should bring value to client like build leverage brand leverage
I agree what you know and then back to what I said like looked like how rugged are you guys willing to live like like
Sharing a one-bedroom with a friend. It's fucking fires me up. So then I would say that you know, look what I do, right?
Okay, Swiss wine. It's like
Vaynermedia, I built other little businesses
So that I can give you all the content for free and not charge you $10,000, right?
So maybe you could do a side hustle. Like I'll give you something while you do this
Why don't you learn how to sell shit on the Amazon that you buy in China? That's just a good skill to have
See where I'm going. Now the sudden you might be making, you know enough to pay your bills on selling a fuckin
Bowties or scraps or camera lenses that you're flipping, you know all this shit
I'm putting is putting it together or
You you get people they're not as big time as these clients that are smaller businesses that you do charge a thousand for a project
But then it comes down to hours
Oh No a full-time client like the person who's falling let's say I got it
Oh in my opinion based on today, I'm ready when you are cuz I don't wanna fuck you up. Okay, I
Think that you need to
Think about who you're doing it for if you go all-in
It's a much better idea to do it for somebody like me what you understand
Give me let me
Assure Ken Carlos
No problem everybody's in this booth, can you um that mic you gotta get right up foot? Thank you. He's good
Thank you very much no worries. Oh wow, Alvin
Real good there life is good. Thank you for having me on
I think an entrepreneur that has motivation and tendencies, you know
I think the thing that I get a little scared of is the life coach and motivation is there's a lot of
Bad stuff out there inside that sphere doing associated with a on the flip side
I so disproportion optimistic and and have that rock coaching in me. So I understand where it comes from
Yep, okay
You know, this is funny
I ran a business the people that don't know a wine store which solves the salesman on the floor and
I haven't spoken and staged my entire life until I did it for the first time at 32 and I and I think it is
important to be transparent it was
Instantaneous for me right gift of gab class clown kind of DNA came through but the biggest thing I did in that first
Speech was I only talked about stuff?
I knew and I think a lot of people trying to make the presentation and talk about things
They don't know so for me public speaking is probably the thing
I'm most naturally gifted him, you know being in the Super Bowl environment here seeing all these athletes you out
The car just came by and said what's up if you look at him?
Even when he adapts like he was broke my body people are gifted with certain talents, right?
I was definitely gifted with the ability to communicate in a way that clearly resonates with people
Yeah, I mean
look
I'm gonna you know back to action being an entrepreneur lemonade stands washing cars
work ethic and
bringing value to customers and wanting money was always a framework and so a lot of my content the reason I mix, uh,
the reason I explode on Instagram in YouTube was not only is it a little bit of hype and the motivation a clearly people like
But I'm giving people
tangible advice
Go do this and you can build up your car wash or start more jam companies or leave your job to paint and do this
so yeah, I'm very
Practical like like uncomfortably being born in the Soviet Union being an immigrant
Growing up with nothing like to me theory is amazing
You have that strategy
But if you don't go executed everybody listening right now has an idea everybody listening thought of humor before a mover
That's all cute. But if you don't execute, it means nothing
Empathy is clearly my superpower when I now that important a little bit more self-aware
I understand that my empathy, you know caring about the other person even this right now
I was talking to somebody I look over and I'm looking over at Jason
I'm like, hey, I'll be ready for one. Like I know he's got something that he asked me to do at one
Just having that you know
compassion that empathy for the other party you'll always win in like kindness and
Gratitude and empathy these soft words. They're actually strengths and over the next decade. I think people start to realize
When you when you've not had a lot of wine in your life, you're not gonna pick up on the nuances now
Here's the here's a crazy secret. I think people should not drink too many 50 60 $70 wines if they want to continue
To you know, drink $10 wines
It's kind of like flying flying private, you know
You don't fly private all of a sudden their whole life you clean middle seat coach, which was more than fine
All of a sudden I hate it
So no
I mean I look now on the flip side are they're $13 wines from
Portugal that in a blind tasting can beat an overpriced $80 Napa cab absolutely so price doesn't mean quality
But there is a fundamental difference in wines across the board
And so there's a big difference between a $10 wine and $100 wine. But 40% of the people listening
They just might like the $10 wine better
They're all passion because I love business and I can execute any business. So I'd rather do it about something I liked
otherwise
it'll be a job and I'll hate so it's the combination of
Everything is opportunity because that's how I see the world but then I put things that I'm passionate about
Like sports like wine like marketing into those buckets of opportunity. I mean I can make a lot more money being a hedge fund
operator right now money is
Really shockingly not a driver towards happiness. And so
I'd rather make money loving what I do. And if I don't make as much as I aspire to that's okay because
It's a perspective right? I'm grateful for being alive
So, you know, I don't know if it's a choice, but it's definitely perspective. Like I'm just like there's always something works
There's only was something that could be worse and I'm I'm aware of that
And so I live my life that day, you know, like if I lose a big five million dollar deal
but what if I got that deal in the next day somebody called me and said my mom was sick like I keep things very
Very minor in basic and so it's perspective more than Janice
I've really appreciated a
You're welcome
Thank you
Of course, I tell you what that empathy thing resonated with me. Thanks. I was a lot more of a jerk
There's a lot more of a jerk when I was 30 than I am when I'm 45
Let me learn you learn learn that right. So that's awesome. Yeah, okay. Thanks for sharing that. Thank you
How are you real good
For you man, that's huge that's good shit
Super well, I'm busy doing the business guys this whole I'm a busy fucking dude. That is absolutely true
Yeah, don't you might get fucking drilled right now
Gotta be careful. Never know. He might just drop it on you diamond cutters come out of nowhere
How many do you orbit got 12 guys and for you know, it was of agile sports up north
Good for you
How long you been doing it about?
Enjoying it. Yeah. Yeah. I like a lot. Yeah fun
I mean my brother and I got into I'm like aegis obviously running day-to-day and like it's been fun to learn
Yeah, I like it my buddy our turn. Yes. Yeah, you you you you want you inserted at Syracuse?
No, we're just family for us. Ahri's good people. That's awesome. You met him up when you when you transferred up at accuse a family
I'm sure all these things under 30 years there do
We got a party tonight and been taking meetings meetings meetings meetings maybe
In life
Well, you know to me it's like, you know
It's almost like a body likes not the liver at a heart of the brain
like Vayner extra baby sports or empathy or the library of guaranteeing, you know, like sneakers of you like it's all
You know, I don't think of them as separate, right?
Yeah. Yeah, I think I think in hindsight when people look back on it like 50 years. Hopefully they're like, oh, okay
That wasn't as dispersed as I thought that was more focus on that
That's what I've heard that's what I heard hey four very sweet I love them on your social
Even well
Good I got to say hi to someone I apologize Thanks. Yeah, of course
Will ya Winnie Winnie
Oh
Nice thank you. Thank you. Hey best of luck. Good kill it today. Yeah. Yeah. Thank you
So I want to get together to New York. It's a done deal top priority meeting
I'll call you we need to and I know where I want to have dinner one of my best best friends is
a
I'm an investor in his restaurant Tyler
When I meet with DDP, we have to we have to eat a beta eight on so literally shit his pants
Oh, yeah
Come out I'm coming up I'm coming up. I'm not sure
I know I'm coming up there with squeaky Whelan and right here in Atlanta
This is where they need you so much sir. My daughter Alexa. Yep yesterday. Yep. Sure. I
Live here additional my DDP other Performance Centre is and what we did is we built that out
So that you know, we can film everything with some cooking shows there all of our workouts
We've got a TriCaster so eight cameras going at one time
So we keep all the movement going. Yeah
I'm ready sit down anything I can help with brother. I'm a fan
A real pleasure. All right
Done deal got my
Cast you do a hell of a job. Thank you get the Jets. I'm really working on it at that time story was awesome
Thank you. Yeah, actually saying the love the good work. Yeah anything I could be help you. Let me know. Yeah
What am I do?
Come on, come on say what's up? I don't wanna bother
Ya see you guys
Don't most aggressive motivational speaker I've ever seen in my pocket Hey Dude, how you doing man? Come here
Yeah, I got my brother my brother and I started a sports agency so we rep a bunch of guys then
I got my marketing share. Do you want I just want to buy the Jets and win a fucking Super Bowl?
I don't want money. I want a Super Bowl. I just want to fucking Super Bowl. Where you over
You mean this game Rams? I'm a big Jets fan like the Jets are might
Like the way you are with Sixers and eagles cut like the Jets have it all
And I'm salty right now about the Knicks that porzingis trade killed. Oh
I got YG t grizzly and a little keyed performing. We have a party a banner sports party
Uh the Fairmont I'll DM you the invite and if I want to bring goodbyes Gary's so fucking dope
Huh?
That's the question this guy's
Gary B's
That's a really good question. That's it fucking relegation. We need to have real dinner. It's a boy
I got a couple things I want this I want to come and just do it right here. It's done
You know what? I love I love what you just
It all cuts out - that guy's gonna ask you a question. Like hey, man, yeah
Fucking stop. Okay. This is why fuck with you. So heavy the amount of fucking work you put in no
No, I know like honestly from like one of the few other people that actually pork that much. They just don't know it
And you know the best part is you have any like haven't even started
I'm not you know
Like I know
This is why this why I really want to try good ass good Dennis and tonight if you want to come through. All right
Okay, nice mean you guys really appreciate appreciate your work
The roof are you heavy? I mean, I love youwith. Yeah, we'll talk soon
Real well was my religious Bill Parcells worst loss. He ever suffered AFC Championship game. He had the Broncos
Hey al played him well any al late you ready for this?
Yeah, I had a hundred and four temperature on the Thursday of that game went to Denver you remember how windy it was?
Fucking I've gone to every Jets playoff game since 1991 awesome
Follow me physically. I've been too long
everyone I
remember walking over the bridge over to the Steelers AFC Championship game loss and I said to my buddy al I said
We're not coming back for a long long time and I've been right and we're not at remotely close
AFC Championship game I get off the plane right away expense
Leon Hess, yeah
Everybody's hand he shook getting off the flames. I know he's three in the morning. It's free season. Thanking everybody for everything
They defer his team that season that was an owner. He was a guru. He was a great guy. He was a sweet man
That's a photo get that. Those are two
Holyfield and Wyler. You missed it. You missed it again. Do you rock? I'm just kidding. I'm kidding
Real pleasure. Hey Kerry, if you guys let me be like, you know, really appreciated. Yeah
Thank you
This is the most important person coming tonight for me, this is moose my college friend, okay?
What time are you gonna get there me I'm gonna if I get there like right at 8:30 early
Yes, man, good
You know what to do. It's just it's hard to give thus
Everything fucking great time
Hit me athletes are as good as that dude a lot actually
Just putting in that work like I know you know
How about car? You know? You got it. I saw you were getting it
It just I couldn't I you know, this is why people around me do well like you have to reinforcement every day
So you don't think having your hands in a little bit of like
We have yo Ventura the real Tarzan Devante a little bit of each kind of like growing our brand
Traveling places rather than just focusing on one
You know reality is I don't think I you know
here's what I would say if focusing on one has to be somebody that you think you're gonna get disproportionate value out of
Otherwise, I like the spread
Exactly, but but if you could do this for Diddy you do it and
Maybe gabbing these three gets you to all of a sudden get a DM from Kevin Hart you like fuck, right?
If you could do it for somebody real special
You know, I think of it as like the talent and the ambition needs to map the people like, you know
like if you write like it's awesome to do it for her ICP rocks all the time now and
They're doing it for like a real estate guy. And that's great if that person's talent and ambition is left, right?
Yep
They're learning the person that they're following doesn't really know the difference. They're learning a little but
Yep, but yes, sir. Yes
Get out of town we're my closest friends so I manage David Smith, that's what so yeah
I really does make me happy
five four years
Stay tight and if you ever fuckin fall right away
Your family
Family, we have a scene show tonight. He'd been talking to me for a long time about you. I'm my brother AJ
Yeah, I'm glad we finally made it happen. Yeah, you met Tyler
Yeah, hi
But nonsense
I talked to him from all time was a big decision for I'm aware and
It's the best fucking decision. He ever made in his life. Yeah, you know he talked to me a lot about you guys
I love you
Often tips on your role. I know when you come to people to receive. Hey, I'm aware
But the truth truth always wins in the end. Yeah. Yeah truthfully these no defense, you know
Yeah, same you're awesome that's a hundred percent. Hi Gary Annie Annie nice to meet you
All right, Todd. What do you got for me? I'm good. Fine. Super Joe. Okay, Donald ostinatos, brother
Okay
Yeah, I want to get out there a little bit
Thank you both preacher, what's your name? Jason Ocean? Yeah, that's what's up pleasure. Thanks for saying what's up. Appreciate it
Yeah, how are you you got a brother no pleasure what's your name Louise Louise nice to meet you
She don't know you Road, but that's something I know
Thank you, thank you brother nice to meet you
Sandy right
I'm starting to drafts more
like I just posted the carousel of the stop like like I wrote it on the flight that that's what
Wake up and when I'm creative I can be like 7
Gary Gary sup, man
Hey you min, Gary Vaynerchuk?
A new man by the jet so they could try and bro. I'm fucking working on it
People don't understand the process people are impatient
people to understand
Can't fucking wait to the end
Where is let's go, how do we get out?
We're uh
Thank you
Here oh right right. All right. We're just going around a little bit
Vin Spinoza with Facebook. How are you? Been good
We were connecting on email I think last week. So we were trying to meet up right. Yeah. I'll be at your party tonight
Great. Are you what are you busy right now? I just jumpy a call with UFC go do it. Don't do it
I'm around here a little bit. Are you are you free in like ten or fifteen or twenty minutes?
Cuz it's so quiet. We can actually have a five-minute conversation. Okay, I'm gonna I mean it's not that big
I'm just kind of you want to show you want a million now. Why don't we move here in 15 minutes not sound good
I'll see that looking forward to it
Of course
Thank You D rock
Thank you, thank you
Whine while you're in there
I'd hit football. Okay?
What up in Atlanta, it's me Gary Vee. I'm here in Atlanta for the Super Bowl
but I want to talk to you about the Super Bowl of wine empathy wines the single best buy you can get
$40 wine for 20 bucks and 50 wines calm. I know the Atlanta wine scene. You need to order this
Yes, and Willie is a huge fan you that's what's unfair that you would be that motivational speaker
Yes and tell myself what I'm and like we do gospel show, right? Yeah, I'm like, I want to get Gary on the show
He's like I'm like nowhere to let him do Gary
later
Good news is I knew plenty things where I don't need to curse. I'm trying to do it
You know what cuz you're not here yet. Yep. Can we just get I would love to give something with you. Yeah horses grab
Take one to take one to kick your mic sir
One two seven four seven four excellent check one two check one two, check check check check check one two seven
One two seven one two seven. There's a little more doing a show. We're here at the
Radio room media meeting Pavilion media pavilion. I there's a Super Bowl. I hope we don't define for that. Anyway here with Gary be
Business just mind of our generation and it's
Thank you so much. Hey just just some simple advice for entrepreneurs coming up. Just your your patience. Yeah
Patience everybody wants it so much right now and that gets it to the next thing get your ears quiet
Everybody is so worried about flossing with in front of everybody else on Instagram and Facebook
Trying to play a role like once you get quiet and you're doing it for happiness. Not for money
Then entrepreneurship gets easy when you're trying to rush into some more money
Because you need it to buy something to look good in front of somebody you start doing things for the wrong reasons outside forces
Get quiet your own head build things for yourself
We have money Mondays on the show and we talk to you know
You know starting new businesses and the main question we get asked all the time is, you know
How do I start and then when I start when do I stop like when do we stop?
Working at our other job. Yeah other job to get startup to go all in on my
You start on the internet after hours after you take care of what you do for a living and taking care of your family
Start a Shopify sell on Amazon start a vlog start a blog start an Instagram account
So you start
you know after hours when you after you take care of your
Responsibilities when you stop is when you can afford this that's good second. You can quit and still pay your bills
and by the way
you may have to move out of a
Four-bedroom house into a three bedroom apartment so that you could start sooner people don't want to downgrade to get to happiness
Which is a huge mistake. So what you start right away because you're unhappy if you're listening right now
And you're unhappy and you want something for yourself. We start tomorrow at 9 p.m
On something that's gonna make you money on the internet you stop doing it at work the second you can afford to
But affording to comes that what are you spending your money on and so that to me is everything
And if and for you
Love you love Ichiro the Shaq video this morning for melody was amazing. Are you rapping? You should come to my party tonight
I'm gonna send you something and for you, you know your personal story of how you made this huge music CD a success
You know, what was the part where you were like, I almost gave up never not I'm telling you the truth
I don't want I don't want to be Bologna on the show. I've never even considered it because
Giving up usually means that somebody doesn't think that they can get the thing
They wanted to me the fulfillment of doing it is the game
Why would I give up the thing I love doing the most?
Business for me is a hobby
You know think about the thing if you're listening right now think about the thing you love the most fishing watching TV playing football
Why would you give it up?
Trying to build businesses. That's why I'm a purebred entrepreneur
I haven't even come close to ever giving up have I had tough days of course, but giving up something. I love that's crazy
Yes, Oh
Got it. I understand very
Simple to me and it's the question. I asked all time
But what I don't know what my passion is, it falls into two categories one. You do know what it is
You're not willing to articulate it or you don't think it could be a business
you might be crazy passionate about worms and you're like I can't say that like
That's silly and how do I make money? You don't realize that you could make five hundred thousand a year
From bait companies for fishing like you don't see it
So either you don't want to say it cuz you don't think you can make money of it or you just haven't tried enough things
I'm
Starting a business that I do podcast. Yes, I produce podcasts and I'm just trying to build the business. Yes for me
It's always been price point. Yes. I've always been told, you know, look people are making money off, I guess right away. They're wrong
I can't you got it. I can't you're gonna win. I can't sell it
Okay
So that's what they told me about the Internet and email and Google and Facebook and social and video and audio and Alexa
Nothing makes money at first the NFL used to not make money guys Super Bowl one was not sold out
Guys Super Bowl one was not sold out in attendance. I don't want to tell you right
The podcast thing is real right the end
Stay alive, and then you'll get your money. Yes, sir. Yes. I appreciate the time
What's the contact for you, sir? Just like your people via rocks gonna be my email right now that you guys got you
That's called mind of med
Well lock-in. Yes, sir
No, it's not so you mean to fill out the form we're doing it right now fill it out it's real
All right, well you could tell me if it doesn't work
Let him know who you are
Is Montana White Street watch exhale I'm here he talked to Moshe he do is
Pick it up motivate the people, you know, Ryan ladies and gentlemen
It's also Gary Vee entrepreneur somebody that's trying to get people to stop making excuses and do something you got one life
That's right. Do something with it do?
Problems. He was a patchwork. Yes
Do something
Gary Vee cross all social that's right Superbowl 53 what you got?
I'm trying to leave Sunday morning because I hate the Patriots was my entire heart. Yeah, so I'm not watching the game
I'm doing business in and I'm out take this out last night. We have 50 cent V love right along right?
We got Yo Gotti tomorrow night little boo. See it's Sunday night money bag
Yo, so if you want to come up
They love it. I DM you and the meat and the Vayner sports party tonight has ygt, grizzly and little keyed
Sure
Big fan give you journalists. What's your guess words of advice sir for your career yet for you?
Yeah, I mean to me what do you want to do? You got us we gotta go backwards
And what would be the ultimate like what is this? And I do what I want to be big Eric you can be
DM and email people on LinkedIn
The people that are that the biggest levels in your world and ask them if there's anything you can offer them the end
I'm not kidding you go home right now lay in your bed and you email on LinkedIn or DM the hundred Titans of what you're
trying to be and
In the title says is there anything I can do for you? If one of them answers it will disproportion of your career
Yeah, of course
The key yeah, of course nice to meet you, Nick
So I got my man Gary Vee everybody knows who he is I mean the legends the icon
So what advice would you give for up-and-coming media personality wants to do radio and TV. What should they do?
put out content for free on YouTube SoundCloud Spotify
Instagram its content your one your one this one because I'm on it might be the one video that gives you the exposure that
Changes the course to your career. That's my career story many others. I gave one speech at the Javits Center in 2007
I said Smurf it up. It went viral and it changed the course of my career
Now it took another 10 years before it really got crazy and weird stuff like this happens
But it's consistency of content and putting it out. And now you don't need somebody to sign you. Look what we're doing right now
She's in the middle the convention center. You've got a phone for we didn't grow up with this like you're making content
Nobody's signing you that this would have taken nine months and a miracle if somebody's saying you're good enough
So make content stop crying about it last day. You got banner you got Vander Sports I do
Look the best kicker in the world Michael badly badly. Yep, Los Angeles charges. What does that mean for you?
Well, that bad story is even better because badge
Was a kid that not a lot of people were sure if he would get drafted
I did one face time with him and I was like this kid's special
I just like him and if he doesn't even make in the NFL, I'll just hire him so we signed Badgley
He goes undrafted. He goes to Indianapolis. He dominates there but they got Villa Terry so they cut him
We're caught, you know, Brian McLaughlin his agent who works for me call and call calls
We get him a workout at the Chargers. He crushes it. They have him on the radar
They put him on the practice squad their kicker struggles. He comes on a team now. He's got a he's got his NFL shot
He goes and dominates but this kid is a ball little Badgley might end up being the president United States
People understand money badger is the man. I love that kid with all my heart. He's got swag coming out of his face
Gary Vee
developing of course
Your party, and I know I know I can't wait to see that document my boss see everybody. No, I'm not awesome. Thank you
Thanks Gary appreciate
All your stuff done 65 log shows her own compassion, yes
Super starting to follow me like crazy. We're in here in Atlanta raised 10k for the huge human society, but for you
I keep it we're keeping doing it. So here's anyone who hears me quick, please
Here's my quick one page for all about compassion change in the world
I want to do my brother's 10 years under the valency has Crohn's. Oh your brother's too crazy hers has Crohn's yes
I want to do one event in New York. Okay your area to raise awareness for so I'll jump in real quick
Oh, you got a email age 8 since it's his disease and his world. Okay anytime this comes up
I always have to go through him as you can imagine good scores and you can imagine
This is so authentic that it may capture his attention. You should email him. Okay? All right. Thank you. Yeah real pleasure
Yeah, of course stuff
We do thing on fashion I of course
Hey guys here with Gary Vee and what's your take on compassion? Well since I push empathy there so kissing cousins, right?
I think compassion is a foundational strength in our society. That way too many people don't execute
Do you mind
And then what you said was great thank you, thank thank you hi
Engage
In your Instagram by replying to every comment on every post
You're welcome. You understand you take a photo people you're pretty and all this stuff, but if you don't reply
Then you're not real to them. You're not building an actual community. You're just asking people to consume your content. Okay, got it. Yes
See you, how are you?
Thank you. It's so good to see you. So could you see what you're going on? I'm now working at CBS news radio
I love it. There's the editorial manager. I love it. I've been doing a lot of other things in between, you know when you
Email you started this email me your email me and you talk to my daughter till we've having a hard time
It's good. I can help ya. You know Mike I will help you back. Okay, I like you thankou l-- I miss you, too
Send me an email. Okay? All right. Yeah
Pleasure came in shot of course
Real pleasure man. Thanks for being patient. I noticed there's a quick selfie video to your mom
I know I don't like I know who your sign. Oh
I'd love to say what's up. It's a legend Garren Oh, what do you want to say to the world Gary?
You've got one at bat. I have no idea why people are dwelling and complaining about dumb shit fucking do something with it
So hey Matt, that's me. Hey, Matt
How I can edit it Thank You Man. Thank people talk to people say you're shorter Doral
I know people tell me I'm taller in real life, which is like devastating like how short do you actually think I am?
Can you put like I know you get shoes mate? Can you get put some spilled? Can you get your coats?
And your can your thing what I am what I am. What are the stats? Say? You are 510 511 5 7 5 8
Yeah, that's what does that say? Okay. I don't give a fuck about how tall I
Like I'm not cliche dude pleasure man be well you too
Yes, are you?
Thank you, bro. So yes talk to the people about what they need to do to get that things going man
They need to stop hearing other people's voices
Most people don't do shit because they're insecure about what other people gonna judge them. Right? Right the end, right? That is fun
That was that that was so meta. I don't give a fuck that I'm five. Seven five eight five nine five ten. Whatever
There's right. Whoo. Yes, what cool you're 16, you're fucking idiot. Like like I'm not worried about that shit
And so people worry about dumb shit
And so if you could actually get to a place where you don't value other people's opinions over what makes you happy
Shit gets good. I
Appreciate you right?
Sorry, just bounce around
Barb you sweetie good
Tyler get me Tyler. I don't want to sketch it. I just saw where okay, my what's going on with the Facebook thing?
It's right now right through Sandler Gary. I'm handling myself
Restaurant awesome T Rock. Let me go do the Facebook. Okay, here's what we do. Yeah hundred percent no way
Short the answer is yes all of it
Awesome week with Robin to david destiny. I love that come over bullshit. It's done
So go do that so I can be here at 205 205
205 okay, and then how long will you need me? It's great to 10 to the tables you tell you right where the rams?
Pretty girl with the big pants. It's moved on it right there pink pants 210 you're where you're not excuse on right there wet
So you the guy in the pink hoodie?
Yep. See, I'm we're not you're gonna steal right up to him. If you're gonna be doing it the hard intersect
Do you rock get me give me the Facebook guy I
Sure anything it's a hundred percent. Thank you. Right I met you with the Lewis house. It's great to see ya
I'm coming
Terry can you do Australian might yeah, I'm set will be the best time to do it over you mean over here. Yeah
I'm gonna be I'm literally gonna go in there for a full hour and do a ton of shit in like 10-15 minutes
Okay. All right. I'll see you in there
Yeah, let me say what's up the cafe. You're welcome. Say with
Some legends real pleasure man. There's a lot of fun watching do your thing from you real impressive shit
I mean it. Yeah, well, I am very well
Yes
Real pleasure. Yeah real pleasure. Oh good
I'm coming to you rock
I'll reach out if there's anything you ever think we could do. Have you let me know if I can help with that
I'm going to do some meeting for 10-15 minutes are done. I've got like six requests in there
Thank you, brother I appreciate
In there thank you, bro. Thank you. Thank you. Alright, let's share. Let's uh, you have credentials to go in here. Yeah, right
That's a
Movement. We're cool Congrats a new game. I've searched it. What uh what?
You have any contacts on me like my world? Yeah. Yeah, I know. Yeah
Yeah, so like and then and vote like veiners for like all the different stuff. I'm up to
Yeah anything so what stands out like what in this new role can I bring you value?
Let's not film this cuz I'm you're so young
You just are your number one moved with all these kind of players is to bring them value
Don't worry about what's in it for you. Of course, that's what I've been doing more
harder
Cuz then something will come to you that's quick you'll see it yeah you understand. Yeah give
Ya been doing this kids. Don't feel like anybody's taking advantage of you. You're giving without expectation. Yeah
All right, let's do this where we going
Okay, how are you good to see you
Like he like, where'd he go?
Yeah, no, no, how are you good
This guy first in there that guy first then I'll go there there and I'll be right next to Oh
He's gonna come on
Can the zebra good to see you go back
Hi Alicia nice, Alicia
Are you doing real good d rocks here somewhere I don't know that's the band you're looking for
Can I do this, yeah
Love it. Let's go. I love it hundred get anything. Are we live right now? No, no
Certain guys are cornering the sports market right now and decided to take over all the other
And there's water let's go yeah we gotta talk about you see you don't know that
Tell us about what made you want to get into it was bad news
I'm feeling it's a legacy play. I watched a lot of your content. What was the deciding factor?
It was I always think about things in macro and then serendipity, right?
so the macro is I want to buy the New York Jets and
Since I was seven eight years old and as I've gotten more educated and smarter and older and wiser, I realized you know
I want to be a great players owner
You know just you know, as I became a good manager of people and you guys have a little sense of yeah
I'm a good guy. Like I was like, okay, that's what good is
That's me. My stick I'm gonna be the greatest owner in sports history that loves his players way more than anybody ever did it before
That nalle' me bounce. I wore a Walter pal Jets Jersey which was a
practice squad fringe player of the Jets custom because that's how I flex I
flex by wearing weird jet players to jet fans to show him a bigger fan than a
His agent saw it is like why do you he's like Walters parents don't have a Walter Jersey. Why do you have this?
I'm like, I just read we started DMing that was it three months later diem squeeze. I call me
I called because jet stuff, you know, he's like do you want to buy a
Sports agency he goes. We're having some problem problems with our money people. Yeah. I'm like, yep
Just like that in the airport. I'm like, yes, I would like to buy your company and so to go real quick
We bought it. I'm just gonna watch learn my brother AJ
Huh, you know he has Crohn's disease and so he was stressed with the big company. We're building vaynermedia walked in
He's like I don't like this and it doesn't make me feel good stress is bad for Crohn's
I'm out him what he Hebert, uh being retired. He you know, 29:18 retires gotta rethink his life
Sat down on a vacation was like, you know what I want to run this sports agency
I wanted to be a sports agent when I was a kid. Maybe I should run it. Call me
I was like bet let's rebrand it to Vayner sports
Let's go all in and let's change the game and that's how it happened now
I've noticed that a lot of a lot of your staff is very young
Yes, a lot of young guys and I met a lot of your guys. They're very
Well-spoken. Very people people friendly guys. How do you how did you its dictatorship?
I mean it I'm a dictator of kindness
yeah, like they represent me like I think kindness and gratitude and empathy and all these things that guys didn't grow up like
You know, like you know anybody who knows who I am was listening
Like I've exploded on Instagram which is where the cultural attention is, and I've exploded in the culture not just in overall
But I'm pushing
be nice and
Like be patient and like you don't need you like I'm pushing things that make people like if it's like I'm aggressive
I've got my energy. It's alpha but it's very soft skills
So if anybody that works with me, I don't know upfront
I hire men and women every day and then you watch and I know who I am and I tell them up front
I'm like, no politics don't shit on people like this is what we're about
most people understand some people don't believe you they just think it's about the money that I got just talk and
Then those people get fucking fired
You know one thing I watched a lot of your concert one. Thank you. One thing that
How good-looking I am just trying to guess yes
Yes
Or or if something they don't succeed they think they're succeeding right now
But they're about to get punched in the face and I'm scared for how they're gonna deal with it
And so I'm trying to get them to be okay with it because if they're uh, no K with it
They're gonna lead to depression and suicide and that's the back end of this entrepreneurial wave that nobody's talking about yet, but go ahead
Yep, so I guess what would you say?
To win
happiness
like right now
Especially when you lost the first time now you want to prove to every right that ship on the shoulder gets real big
Right. So what that's gonna lead to is you got a little something going now and what it usually leads to again is you're gonna
Try to make a move that overextends you again. It's not gonna be as stupid and ridiculous as the first time
But where people get caught is not experienced people get caught an insecurity of judgment of others
The reason I'm gonna win the whole damn thing is I don't give a fuck what anybody thinks about it
It's so quiet up here. You can't you can't like you can't and
That's it. And that's it. And so what's the second mistake?
Patience don't you don't need to have you know, don't look over there and be like yo, that's gonna be us next year. No
It's not
It's not gonna be you next year it gonna be right here again. Maybe the year after that you might have two tables
you understand, but I know you walked into your Center fucking ditch, you know, that's what right that's where people get caught I
Do that too. I do new things I come in but I say I'm gonna be there nine years
Right, that's gonna be me in 15 years, but people like people like flawed like stupid like, you know first year
They're just happy to get a quick shot
Prudential this year here and they're talking about being able to see next year then doesn't make any sense
It's an instant gratification of world now because it's based on insecurity. It's not instant gratification
You're insecure you worry about what other people think you only have 50 followers
You didn't get that many likes you'd only have this much money. You don't have a fat watch
You know, I'm the girl, you know, the guy you don't have indicated like people worry about other people's opinion your parents
I'm gonna prove to my parents who shit on me my whole life that I'm gonna do it
Like I'm I'm gonna prove to that girl that said no to me wait
wait
Does she sees when I got the Lambo then she's gonna want like dumb shit living life for other people
Living life for other people that you don't even like a lot of times
I'm passionate about this
Yeah
Let me go I'm really interested in this watery thing that you got going on water a wine
While the wine to know what the watch at charity water what water though. There's a water that I keep hanging in my office
Yeah. Oh, that's just one. That's our water in the office. We just put vaynermedia on it
Like it's just some good shit for ourselves. Not yet, but but not yet. Not yet. Listen
listen now that we did this if this clip goes if you really go I want the water but this is business man I can
Be sold on selling water
But but no the water you keep seeing obviously in the clips is just our office water that we slap. So I'm like
Listen listen, I'm trying to take over everything. I noticed that yeah, that's right. How many Allen?
Love you, bro, how many how many businesses all of them?
Meaning, you know a lot a lot Vayner acting how many different genres?
Out real fast on one board people Vayner ex is my main world. That's where vaynermedia sits. That's where one thirty seven pm sits
That's where pure Wow sets. That's where Vayner speaker sits. That's where his new company Sascha sets
Tracer that's my kind of like conglomerate company outside of that. I've the wine business empathy
I have a nurse sports with AJ
I have Green Street the cannabis agency because I had a separate deck because of laws out of
So I've got I've got other set, you know the family business Wine Library
I'm always keeping my eyes on even though it's my dad's business
then there's the whole business of being Gary Vee right the case Swiss collaboration books public speaking out do
Poor things
Lack of judgment. I don't judge myself
What shit hits the ground when you got 84 balls in the air seven are gonna fall. Guess what?
I still got 77 in the air. I'm glad that you have one
That's one to gratitude I'm just grateful I'm happy I'm thankful
Like, you know people I love aren't sick like or dead. I keep it that basic if you want to be very transitory
Aliy ask me what the motor is of this whole fuckin the thing that whatever the fuck I am
It's cuz I only care about 15 people not dying
And as long as they're not dead or haven't been, you know announced critically-ill. I just think every day's good
I don't like losing money. I don't like losing. I don't like having a business fail. I don't like somebody quitting
I don't like somebody leaving a comment in my section saying I'm an idiot like I don't like it
But but it doesn't get there. It doesn't bring me down. I'm grateful for the app back. Ok
Lily can't let you leave without a jets question. Yes
I feel like we're close. I'm not kidding. I I'm on the record
No, but I think Donald's real and I'm telling you guys I think Adam GaSe is real
I think this is Pete Carroll. I think this is Belichick
I think this is a kind of like guys if you would listen I hated him for three years
Right if you looked at what he did there Tannehill was hurt more than half the time. He made Brock Osweiler guys
Everybody's throw shade on him about Peyton Manning all he's ever done his pain if you look at Brock
Osweiler's and John Kipnis career stats, they're single best years were with Adam GaSe
I'm telling you right now you go talk to actual dolphins that played last year
If you go talk to rookies, you'd go talk Jerome Baker and clean-limbed balázs
Like I'm telling you guys Adam gay and by the way might not even happen with us boy. Would that crush me?
Adam GaSe is gonna win in this league. So Adam Darla's the best human on earth
If you really know who he is, I think there's something man. We got money. We got draft picks
I think we're I think look in three years. Have you told me the Jets were at this game?
I'd be like I understand how we got there and I didn't feel I actually
Never felt that way outside of Chad pettings its first year. I didn't feel it with Mark. I didn't feel it with Geno
I didn't feel it, you know with boomer sighs somewhere. I was a kid. Yeah
Only after Penningtons first little run did I feel it and I feel it again for the first time know?
Who's your pick tomorrow?
I think the Patriots are gonna win, unfortunately, and I hate them with all my heart. I put the Patriots up there with Hitler
But that's where I'm at. Unfortunately, that's who I think is going to win
Thank you for having me thank you bro, you see
Can we get a pig
Are you such a pleasure? How are you I'm excited for Trumpler. We're a little tricky
He's in the zone let's go
I'm we do these coconuts have milk in them are these real?
Yes
This is huge. This is what I'm about this. Just coconut pop up. Let's do it brother
This is mine. This is my camera. Yep. That is your microphone. Yep, and you have good levels here
I feel great cock yourself this way and say do it Darren you set
You said?
You've got to go. Yeah, I mean are we doing anything you you're fine where we supposed to like you want to?
You good, okay
Letta alright
He did okay ready, I'm ready. Let's go rock and roll here we go in three two
W- k-y-t's awesome more and
I'm not cutting to the chase. Finally Gary Vaynerchuk
Finally, our time is come. Well Wine Library TV. I met you at blob with blobs with balls
Yes back before you were the Gary Vee back before crushing and all that good stuff
You're not first thing you put a shout out for Trott's Lansford
Yes, you have some fascination with trucks ice-covered Barry trots his first team 1987
We've been friends for 32 years hoisting the chalice a goblin
Over Las Vegas together. What do you want that you want? Is he changed Long Island yet or what?
Well, it looks like he's in the process of one of my dearest dearest friends Mike
Aya is the biggest Islanders fan of all time and we were having an ex exchange
About how cool it is that with all this weird stuff that's happening with me the attention
That a lot of the people that we love are now reaching out to me to say hello. So we call it the family
So trots is apply. You're my family. You don't know because we collected baseball cards
It's the same thing, you know the whole deal. I like some wine your Energy's like mine. No, no, no
No, your Energy's like mom's. I'm older than you and I've been doing this to maxim. Do you look at the music?
You're doing vaynerchuk's. I'm like
It's 1992. Let's go Eddie. So I think that um, my really good friends like I need to become friends with him
He's a huge Hollanders fan
So he's one of the most magnanimous human being I can't wait to meet I've ever literally killed
I want to desperately take him out to dinner so I can bring my friend Mike and try to figure out how I can bring
Him unbelievable values since he's brought so much happiness to my friend Mike in six months
I let him know that only text the other day when I saw you so that's connected
Now let's get to the bottom line here using the internet connect us ask what that's okay
put us on a three-way tag on will be all connected you using the internet for
Greater good and for bigger causes I know that that's at the heart of what you're trying to do
I'm gonna add a very challenged City in Baltimore. Yeah, and I want to pick my city up this year amongst other
We'll do more positive things. Tell me where the Internet is not just for making money in commerce
Not just for spreading aid and getting orange people elected president of our country with Russian help
I'm talking about making the world a better place because the Internet is going to be a part of that
So well, the Internet is the foundation of communication
So you're talking about the Internet is is funny to me because the Internet's like oxygen
What's the Internet's point in making the world a better place?
it's it's the fact that that's where communication thoughts and ideas will be formed and
Lived out and so right now the good and the bad, of course the good in the bad cuz sometimes the bads winning though
No, sometimes I'm gonna love this the bad winds up front
because what the what the Internet's current state is doing is exposing a lot of things that we didn't know about ourselves or
We chose not to look at I think you give me an incredible value for truth. When all this is over
We don't for Integrity's it is now
Amongst a good people know amongst the truth is good and bad truth exposes
Brother, do you understand how many people spew hate on Facebook today and all day and 37 years from now
We're gonna have to answer to their 12 year old granddaughter and are gonna be mortified and deserve to lose
Do you know how much truth the Internet has let me tell you about seventy. Let me tell you about nineteen forty seven-year-old
Racist Rick he got to rewrite his history that he wasn't
Let me tell you about 2019 racist Rick on the record, my friend
The Internet is going to expose the greatest truths of society because it's documented at scale and you know what I think about that
Tremendous so it's a little uncomfortable now
But once people actually quantify what's going on here the next 200 years are gonna be remarkable
You're at on the web every day talking about what you're doing and fifty thousand eight hundred thousand feet
I just got back from Tony Robbins. I did a fire walk with Tony in 1990 changed
My life was two weeks before the baseball story. I'm in a baseball only city. No football team was ever coming
Yep, Charlotte, Jacksonville. Got the expansion teams
I sat at the bar with a bottle of champagne that was never to be opened Wow that night the
Jacksonville got a team in front of us
Okay, you lacks emotion having team. Now two years later the miracle happens Art Modell shows up in the parking lot
Brian billets my partner here of 22 years ago in sports radio and fulfilled my dream at 50
I want to see Robins last month spent a week with him date with destiny about what the next thing is
and I know you've had a lot of that from
Parents with liquor store baseball cards wine library and then what to do with it?
And I've watched what you've done with it from that day the blobs of balls in the basement of that
beer joint in the middle of Manhattan a decade ago Homer to see what's happened to your destiny, but but
Strategizing the next thing for you fader media owned the Jay you got all these things
But but on a daily basis, you can't do all of it, right?
No
And I think it's okay to juggle a lot of different ambitions and wants and flees and and I enjoy that I enjoy
Juggling 55 balls in the air and of 22 fall they fall, you know when you start not worrying about judgment
Things get really interesting when I'm not worried that if one of these businesses fails then I got hot you're not you're not good
I'm like, okay, that's fine. That business didn't work. I had the wrong partnership
We have the wrong value proposition, but talk to me about the net
You know your 2000 Ravens won the Superbowl, right? Sure. They had some flaws in that team
Actually when I think back then team they had some flaws
Well, I just had the bad day the football people thought the quarterback was right
so so I think that you know to me I'm a I'm a
360 human and entrepreneur and I
Like juggling a lot of things and this goes back to what I care about the most and I get back to us being family
I'm kind of starting to you had more context than I do and I'm already picking up. I look when you love what you do
It's real good. Like we need to scream. Yeah, I'm
26 Superbowl I dream to going to one. I'm a pretty lucky guy dude. Literally. Thank you. Thank you for joining me
Here's how I look at
Someday soon. I hope and I'd like to be one of the voices and I'll take many voices
I'm not even remotely close to a big enough platform
someday soon
I hope that happiness
Genuinely being happy is something that people strive for in the same way that they strive for money if we can get to that
They can get real good real fat
But part of that's needing
Significance and needing certainty and all the stuff that we talked about with Robbins and date with destiny a hundred percent
I mean there's a lot of variables to that but honestly above all that because a lot of that can get pretty altruistic
How about self-awareness?
How about how about the fact that we need to start talking about self when you actually know yourself. How about finding out?
Why you have insecurities who instilled that in you and why when all of a sudden you become?
Compassionate and empathetic to your mom who actually did a bad job in parenting you but you realize well
that's because she dealt with X and
That manifested down to me all of a sudden you can start forgiving you can start taking a step back
I just think that people do well on their shortcomings or what they can't do
Instead of being excited about the one or two or four seven things they can do
Where's your well for personal development, you know, sometimes I come to you sometimes I go to jail robbed
Sometimes I just sit in the window and with my tack, you know what I mean?
And think about things for you personal development for you
Would what do you work on an on an annual basis to get better see question?
I'll ask Robbins when I have him on you know
You know for me, I don't consume stuff
so usually it's the energy of the feedback loop the audience itself or just very
Insular close my eyes in my own self. I'm very I'm very good at being a cocoon
I haven't been able you know, it's a really tough, you know, it's tough because this is not a fun
I don't this answer is tough for me
Because there's a level of audacity. There's a there's mixes to being to answering what I'm answering which is nobody it's not a human
It's a feedback loop from the audience and some version of me being insular with myself
And having the conversation in myself, that's just the truth
And and and I you could see the tone changed a little bit
Like I think it's I'm trying to understand it
Because I think it's good a lots happened to you since the last time I saw you in the basement
Yeah, but that's from the outside right if you and I were homies since fourth grade
You would know how much everything stayed the same. I see if the Jets games
I know, you know what I mean, it still burns. It just always have Super Bowl three though
We have that don't be mean just cuz you got one I gotta go. Hey many. Well, yes
thank yous conveyor chugging Jeremy go buy the books go follow a million-two and and
Trott's I need to get that's done. Thank out on that. All right there
he goes
Gary Vaynerchuk were live on radio wrong all of our Super Bowl fifty three covers brought to you by our friends in Life OK
So much respect to you, but I'll be watching yo fuckin hustle
We got to get you on ballers, let's go fucking talk about sweet mean exhausted we agree a hundred percent on it
Chicago, let's get together and really chop. You'll really know how much I really have bro. You know them I'll away
Thank you, thank you real pleasure
Beautiful follow and DM me right now lock you
So much
So the first question loss to both of you. Yes. What is Belichick know that nobody else does?
What does Belichick know that nobody else from my perspective? He knows a process of?
Reverse engineering his athletes to put them in the best position to succeed which is a management style
That is unique most managers come in with this is what I do and you're gonna figure it out. I
Believe from afar that I hate saying this because I hate him so much that I hate him and the past
But I think what's made me successful is I look at them, even when Tyree started working from marketing standpoint with Vayner sports
I don't want to make him do things. He's not comfortable
I'm trying to get to know him and then I'll bring him opportunities that he's gonna say yes to
Instead of like I don't want to do a three days shooter. I don't want to read from a teleprompter
And so I think cuz I don't know but I blocked a lot of Patriots football being a died or jet ban
My intuition is that he reverse engineers players and puts them in the best position
Do you hate him so much just cuz he's AFC East if he was somewhere else you'd respect him
Do you know that Bill Belichick was the New York Jets head coach twice twice twice?
I've never coached a game like
Just like, you know, like one should talk about life
He was the Jets coach some champ. He was the Jets coach twice and
Never coached for them and then went on to be the greatest head coach in NFL history. So what do you think I think?
I mean, yeah, definitely. So for me, I mean just growing up watching Tom Brady Bill Belichick, you know
They've always been kind of at the top. I don't have any ties to any team
So I things a great coach and I loved what they've done and you know
I think that they do a good job of just staying consistent. They're consistent year
They kind of go about it the same way and come this time of the year. They're always
to be playoff
and
It's just truly and now I got to just tell everybody because this actually happened I had a nightmare
Four days ago that I reacted by the Patriots
Well, if you guys do what you do, you're it's like it's not gonna happen, but I have to ask you
Yes, what your brother? Yes, you gotta like beyond pitch yourself. I'm here with my brother
Yes at the Super Bowl reppin athletes my gosh
Are you like this is my life. You know AJ and I are really bad at smelling roses
But once in a blue moon, we're bad at smelling roses or celebrating wins. I saw how much I asked him out
But once in a blue moon
We'll like get into some sort of quick text. I'm actually just in it, but I had less to do with the Super Bowl
I think nonetheless
Yes, it's not remarkable
And like if we had this conversation if we saw the things that are happening in our lives 20 years ago
The way we were sports fans and then our youth like and we're obviously 11 years apart and just it's really it's really cool
Yeah the agency yeah than that, yep like it's such a whole mood like I could like
I'm not a shoe guy so I don't care about that
But this to me is like we're gonna say we're gonna rep athletes and then they're actually gonna think us seriously and I'm shopping. I'm
moving freaking sharing the wire
That Leigh Steinberg. I love it. So yeah
Yeah, I think so
Anyway to me to me, of course
And and where it's even more important is the following which is we're not just gonna be in it
We're gonna be the single best sports agency in the history of the industry
We're just because we're great and we're good people we're talented and we're patient so you know what?
So I'll be very frank
What's exciting about Ty reenact Allen Robinson just came up on with us like like for me
these guys are gonna be the OGIS of it and they're gonna benefit the most
Like right like they're gonna be the original crew
So I'm forever when I'm 73 gonna be putting them on and their kids on
Because they were the ones that helped along the way and then it's gonna be this
I mean, it's just it's it's been written my friends
So besides the I'm gonna teach them how to do social and have that personality. There's nothing I know
Ya know I did
I mean, I'm going to support them as men
Right, like like I'm just gonna be there for them when their mother dies when they want to sign a second deal
I've Jerry I think so. Yeah, I know so I don't know the movie well and have how big in your roster be
Well, we're doing it with vaynermedia
now we have a thousand employees and when you do two hundred million dollars, the answer is a lot if you surround you
You know like like well
I'm just looking when I look at Tyler like it scares me to know what Tyler's going to be able to do
He may not want to do it with me. That's I understand that but
Quite a bit like like like you can scale when you like that Patriots have had a lot of different players
They've had a lot of different years. They've been different names on the jerseys, but the infrastructure at the tops been the same
So again back to that people watch what he does
Like it every team says this next man up that's been up the Patriots, you know
They'll use three running backs in a game you never but that's because they've the one or two pieces at the top that matter
Here's something that's been consistent Bill Belichick and Tom Brady. One thing that will be consistent of Vater sports is me and AJ
Do you understand?
But dude, what about Bill Walsh and Joe Montana named Bill Walsh and Steve Young
Well that well, that's why Bill Walsh and and Joe Montana won
But but it didn't last 15 years. Well, that's because ownership is actually the top
So what does Robert Kraft know that we don't know that he has to put people in the position to succeed you
Have to you have to feed a players, right?
Like like when you have an a player you have to know what he or she wants and you have to feed them
Sorry, let me ask you a question
I'm now I'm bouncing around a little bit changing up the contact like as a quarterback
Which is the leave in that structure of what's happening on the field?
I assume that you've had to adjust and pander to wide receivers left tackles like right
That's not me I feel like out of quarterback you have to know your teammates you have to know the
Loser, you got to know the guys around, you know
Your teammates and like you said if you're a little weaker I'm saying you got a you know
I'll come for that another way. If a receiver can only run these routes, you gotta know that
Instead of being pissed that oh, my god has a one that were Stephen enforcing and thrown picks
But I can't run the route exactly. So where'd you go to school? I went to Buffalo
I'm gave up run and where is he right now slated to go or do you know or I mean?
what's really the biggest thing I've learned about a
football and I was a die-hard fan and now I'm really in the business is mock drafts are not that good because
because the media doesn't actually know like
No, I mean they know they have thoughts but like we have better date
I'm Way better data now and we still don't know right like we're talking to actual scouts actual GM's and someone we're having actual
Conversations with you. They're not smoke signaling you but like I don't know like look
But by the media standards people have Tyree in the third round on average. There's people that he can you go second round
There's people that think he can go even late first if it gets crazy in, Indianapolis
There's people in the fourth round and he's what I like about him is I listen I'm speaking for you you'll speak
Let me tell you why I desperately was holding my breath that Tyree would side with Boehner sports as we worked on this journey. I
Just don't think he's gonna give a crap where he goes. Well, he pissed if he goes six-round
let me save you time he'll be pissed but then the next day's gonna start and we're gonna focus that he's in Cleveland or
Cincinnati or or Los Angeles
How long have you dreamed about the you know?
Whether it's in the big room
There's on the couch with your mom and like that day like coming I think ever since you know
I make the football levantar playoffs five years old, you know, it's one of those things that's always the goal
But it's not the end goal. The end goal is win
A lot of games to do to play go to super all those things
So I think it's just another step in the process and it's just another thing that you know
Just like you want played a bit more football. It's just another thing and you gotta keep going
Alright, well, I know Gary says I'm not gonna spend time working on my weaknesses
However, I feel like the athletes it might need to be my footwork my whatever no no
That's exactly right and I talked about leaning into your strengths and not dwelling on your weaknesses
And so I have to do a better job clarifying certain weaknesses can destroy you coming
So certain weaknesses can destroy you and so you've got to make certain weaknesses palpable. You know, he's a huge dude
He's gonna be the biggest fucking quarterback in football, right? So so I'll show you
So his wind up is gonna be different than a guy that's 6 1 so you got a reverse engineer
We got to bounce I appreciate it dude. Thank you so much
Close it out
Thank you so much what's your name? So nice to meet you thank you for saying that hey AJ
I'm the schmuck. You're the pro. That's what I do comedy. Someone's gotta give the athletes a little sense of humor
I know what am I doing? What am I doing? AJ?
Yes, of course, this is what I'm doing I'm but I can do this
No, go check with your people and their nose you can just give this to you. Thank you miss comfortable man
That's really awesome gonna run this up. You're awesome. Dang sweater. Thank you, brother
Damn respects game
Sup a license for this
Appreciate it man. How are you?
Real good real good. I've said about tonight
You can't imagine it's gonna be all right
The Schmo with garyvee what of chameau the pro of motivation one message right now all the smoke fans Gary, please
Stop fucking listening to people you're living your life based on other people's opinions at the cost of your own happiness
Great message. Appreciate it Gary B
Thank you, thank you thank you so much. All right team where we going
Where we going
Where we going bro
Where we going let's go Scott with Allen. Yeah, let's go
I don't know if ever medley
Please know each other. It's a real pleasure space real pleasure. How are you? Nice to meet you. Have a great weekend. Take care
Thank you, bro
Looking forward to bro
Sure good
You saw boys
All right, so I'm here at Super Bowl weekend with Gary Vee the man himself am I selling my younger guys
I mentor not to fear the worst. What advice could you give up as far as like facing the discomfort of applying?
Other people's judgement is why you are discomfort, right?
Like you worry about other people's opinions
And that's why you don't want to put in the work you lack patience because you want jewelry or money
So this is a game about judgment and insecurity once you know what you love do that, and don't worry about other people's opinions
Love your videos
James Harris
Do it, what do you know? We're at yeah, I say it
I'm good. How are you?
Okay
Brian Weber I met you last year with Kordell Stewart. How are you in the middle? Okay. We'll put out in here
Okay, and you're a pro. You know how I know exactly how to do this
You're gonna be got the best here all day gonna take this thing home
Dude, I like the gold. I was telling Gary we did this last year at the Super Bowl
We're just having a conversation and this is about you your personal brand what you've been doing in the field how you guys hooked up?
social media
But we're not talking about the game
Because everybody else has had you 500 questions about it's Tom Brady the greatest in no time
All right, so and we got time so this is not just quick sound bites. We're just three guys talking. Let's do it. All right
And how long we can do for a millisecond
How long did you guys?
How long ago do you guys what that professional make sure you met at the Super Bowl couple years ago. We'll do that organically
I'll do the Larry. This is Larry know from then older. I get the more in realize he was a genius
That's all you know, it's no preparation be guide, you know prep when you ask the question. It's intuitive and authentic
He did is Blasi but you know, wow, I did it cuz I'm lazy we get to the same spot
Heiser changes everything good for you
Horse horse
Give me one favor. This is loud close. Yep and tomato when we start on wow, you got it
You're allowed to I've heard I'm very lucky. Yeah, whisper. Ah, here we go. Three two
Well Super Bowl. Yeah be chatting with Gary Vee and one of his clients. Haven't Robinson. Hope the Bears felis
Thanks for taking the time. Thanks for having us start at the beginning Alan. How did this partnership come together?
I don't think it's I don't think anybody could say that would be Gary. You know that you only have like one conversation
one wall conversation
Friendship, you know just be able to meet him at that time
And Gary, I know you well enough that you're selective with clients we're not looking for quantity
There's got to be a connection. You nailed that, you know, especially early on
the original 5 7 12 15 guys that we signed here at Vayner Sports are going to dictate our future and
Alan is green because for me
I'm I'm so scared when I look somebody in the eye and say I'm gonna be there for you for real
I'm so ridiculously busy the thought that I have to be there for things that might not be fun is just not interesting
so I need a
disproportionally great human being and
Player, and I really do think the alan is
The model of what we're going for because often it's the client choosing the agency sounds like you guys chose each other
Yeah, and then listen Brandon Parker needs to be he's that he's the reason this is happening
I'm looking at his pretty face right now looking at his phone but like Brandon and
Alan had a relationship long before Vayner sports and when Brandon decided to come to Vayner Sports
There was a there was a natural opportunity for us to build on the relationship that's sparked when we met
What do you know about Gary?
because if you listen to sports talk radio if you're on social media, he's everywhere and
Before the term Russell was out there. My man was doing it some of baseball cards and transforming Stan one distance
definitely as I got to meet Gary, I think the biggest thing is not only
Aspiring entrepreneur, I think that's the biggest thing yours
having the value
Of having a relational and area that received a lot of different size of business and everything that you're able to kind of
You know connected, you know, it's not just about football or it's not just about me playing football
You know, I gained a lot of other knowledge new in fourth
Aspects of business endeavors, you know social medias the images and just opens your mind
Just give being that being able to know how to hustle
You know, I don't think like if you say, you know, just because you're going to gym and workout for eight hours
I don't think that you had a good workout. You have a great workout, you know to get better
So just being able to hustle you don't want to do
it
And it's a you know
It's fun to listen to this because this you know back to being it was fun right before we went on air
We kind of remembered that it was Super Bowl where he met, you know
Allen is very new to the Vayner sports roster because it's all finally got put together, you know
the fact that within weeks
We have a deal where he has a beverage that he's excited about and not only is it gonna get paid to produce content?
But he's getting back-end equity so that what you know, you know people hear about the miracle one-off
You know
vitaminwater deal that David Wright made some money on this is something we're gonna do consistently and I don't want to speak for Allen but
I learned a lot about the sports agency world a lot of agents talk about that and then it doesn't happen and
for what I'm excited about is watching him go through the process of assessing that opportunity and
The fact that we were able to bring him such a significant opportunity within moments of them signing over with that
It's like a big deal when the old days they called that mailbox mother
Like that I got another check yep keeps going on. Yep
Another key word is even for to anything get that but we save that for my business podcast dollars insects that be web
Obviously football was your passion. It's part of your right, but you mentioned business as well
Are you asked kind of deep in that area as you want?
Or knowledge about it to know it is making me that much more
No pushing power or necessarily be good at you know
I think that I'm gonna consider that I am in football because that's what I do, you know
And that's what I've done it for 20 plus years now
Right now I'm Karen
He's trying to get my way
I will say the swimsuit brand is off the ground to be able to produce content trying to get it out there, you know
Just again be around the right people too. They have started stuff off the ground and I think that's the biggest thing
Is that this it's so easy to just jump and be able and they trying to be a part of something great
You know rather than being a part of the start or something
Truth is the only option so
You know what you're alluding to and what a lot of people think about is the downside
I see all upside because I recognize that if I do something wrong that
I will just own it because I'm a human being and every single person in this convention center has done something wrong
Some have been able to hide it
right
But when you get paid lots of money and have a lot of exposure, it's harder to hide
So my big thing is like be you
Like a lot of them feel a lot of pressure to become really good at social media when they sign with us
I'm like, I don't need that
This is a we're a football sports like we're here because we think you're one of the best wide receivers in the game
Now do I think there's things I can help you with?
Will it lead to opportunity and look these are young men?
Like we have to start having empathy some of these guys come into the league. They're still dating
There's like a lot go there's a lot going on in the DM is on Instagram. I'm not naive to what's happening
You try to get them to focus on their core strengths, but it's just a human conversation
I'm not imposing anything and I'm there for them when
Anything happens and if it's something negative the advice will always be we're gonna tell the truth because you're a human being and that's that
They use the term hustle. I think it's become
You know what it means
You embody that on a variety of letters?
But for people listening and watching what about having a purpose hustling with intent? I love that
Yeah, I mean look and and you know some of the stuff about like purpose or fulfillment gets a little tool it gets altruistic
Right. There's people at home that are just trying to pay their rent. So for me, it's actually something else
It's a mix of hustle and purpose and it and it equals happiness
You know
I just think if people understood that happiness has to be the goal and
That like if you're chasing money you're already vulnerable and that
happiness comes in a ton of forms
There's a lot of ways to be happy and if you could just deploy some self-awareness
if you could just deploy some self-awareness you could get
Dramatically happier that to me is what I'm trying to force people to understand that happiness is what you should be trying to achieve
And I'm trying to get people understand making forty-seven thousand a year
But being on on a wiffle ball team that you love and playing for night all night
If you're actually happy then that's amazing. If you're complaining that you have no money
Well now I have to talk to you about 10:00 p.m. To 2:00 in the morning. And so I don't know
I'm I'm on a new kick all together which is like happiness happiness happiness
Oh, it makes you happy to be work at a non-profit. Well, guess what?
You're not gonna own a mansion, you know, you're gonna need to rent but you're happy
And so that to me is like I'm just obsessed with that. Does that message resonate with you?
Give enough time for me as I think I
Mean like honestly, you just said something that can help so many people
Like one more time like you obviously had this great start to your career like did and you play a brutal sport?
Which you know
It's a if there's a different variable that football players are thinking about then some of the other sports
Does it weigh heavy that you're like, oh, man
I got a produce n stay healthy
And if I don't the variable of the amount of money, I'm gonna make is so extreme
Did that just like to start really building on your shoulders?
Most athletes
Like there's nothing what about bad decisions about the people that spend time around them?
That one that that one to me has been like would you wanna play on Sundays too? Yeah
Yeah, if you have it
This is why I am so passionate about Boehner sports you meet this
We I didn't have the luxury with Palin but this is the luxury. I'm having with Tyree Jackson
Do we have this year and others DeMarcus Lodge?
you meet them at this age where they haven't even started and you realize I mean
It was a kid our first year John Toth
He broke his back during the Senior Bowl
Like process like Bill ignored the journey before discerning the begins or back to we've seen a million things born
let's go to the extreme Bo Jackson at the apex of sports an
Industry injury that you and I when we watched it didn't listen did it didn't feel like it was anything crazy
over
This is where I'm excited. The fact that Alan says man injuries can change everything
Well, that's not the way it is an entrepreneurship, you know outside a health
Right, which is more macro than injuries and less common than injuries
the fact that Alan if everything goes phenomenal for him and he's a youngster actually in the scheme of things like
Okay. So what 32 34 I mean look at look. Can you imagine right? I mean, it's 29 Frey
He looked 1 you look great. But like, you know the fact that if everything goes great
For him then he might be 35 years old and done right? He's got his whole life in front of him to challenge them, right?
Because is that how you came up with
No, he came out young he was young
All right
Let's think about that and when we're wrapping up a sexy
Let's he you were to count and you had 12 years of reading accountants and at 32. That was it
And you've been the count here whole life. What do you do in the next chapter?
You'll get there at some point, but that's another challenge
I don't think we discuss enough this mental shift of trends and this is why I want kids in our
Ecosystem from day one if day one and by the way, I'm a businessman and a marketer, but this is not about money
It's about happiness. If day one we're bringing to him how to be a good if I
Brandon could help me
Be a good dad be a good brother be good
If you help them by the time they get to 32 and their transitions the next thing they're a complete man
they haven't just been a
One-dimensional athlete who has hasn't rounded out his life giving back to the community
Nonprofit making money like building your brand. He's a good-looking, dude
This guy could be a superstar actor if he wants to and so like I think the role of football players three and a half
Years on average three and a half years whatever on average we said so yet there so so to me
I'm dying to know about the 32 to 62 years
Range for these NFL and now they're starting to think about that and 20 years ago. They did it final thought
We have a big social media presence and a lot of people followed both you guys
but I'm always intrigued about when it comes to your success as your willingness to be open and share and
Recently had a great post about if someone sitting on their couch just feeling like I don't know where to start
What do you have it you could go down and sell that's right. And what could you do with that? $25 of you? That's right
Yeah, I mean look, I've been putting out a lot of content
A lot of people have been winning but a certain group really grabbed my heart
They were saying I have no money not zero and like they weren't joking. They're like, I'm on welfare. I'm poor. I'm homeless
These are you know, these are people literally emailing me in DMing me
So I said, you know what, I've got to teach people how to get from zero to a hundred dollars
This is you know, luckily some people I can teach from going from millions to billions
but zero to a hundred and so I'm unbelievably passionate about that and I started talking about garage saling and flipping and
In your closet, there's stuff if you don't have money that old sneakers you don't wear it
And it's been remarkable and completely exploded because it brought help to people
There are so many people that an extra 500 bucks a month changes their lives
I like I grew up in that environment a lot, you know many players grew up in that environment
So to me that's been very exciting
I'm thank you for bringing that up it you know sell stuff go the average garage sale has ten items
That is a dollar that goes for twenty dollars on eBay
And if you're willing to put in the work and wake up at 6:30 in the morning on a Saturday
And I think if you're hungry and unhappy you should be willing to do that. Great to see you guys
Thank you
All right
Are you interested in DCU and this seems right up
Yes
Speakers built-in
Thank you so much
Thank you
Bro it's real pleasure. And so blessed when I blog man how we doing here, man
Live it listen medicine honor to hang out with you. The syndicated radio show. I'm aware
We often use some of your inserts love what you do in there. Keep doing your thing, man. I'm all about it
We just talked about
I don't know Tyler. What are we gonna get this kids photo and real?
Where's Tyler if I can get you to sit down with him? I can be great. Yeah, I think so
Thanks Ben. So my pleasure preciate it
Love you on the bar. So thank you bro. Amazing. Thank you, brother
You know what
I
Don't let's move a little I want to grab the wrench or
Yo ya do we need to do that, you know, what are we go to a turn I got to see tire
I got a seat. I
Missed I recovered a chance car
We dancin I love it. I love it my plum happy to do it
We're gonna roll there's some moving is how we're doing it to
Move and podcast maybe
Gary be second out with your nephew will suffer breath. Tell my man. Thank you so much for having me on that's very nice
What up, everyone?
Yes
Nope, and as a matter of fact the process of trying to buy the Jets is my great passion
So to be very frank, I'm not in a rush. Okay, for real?
Listen I'm looking for partners when the time comes so if you're if you're gonna make some real wealth over these next 10 15 years
Let's do it. I'm about it if they well they so you keeping yourself in shape man
What are you looking forward to the most here Superboy?
I know you have a lot of people that you pour into a lot of these guys watching weekly and so like what are you?
Looking forward to the most you at the Super Bowl just spend time with my guys my brother AJ and I started Boehner sports
So we represent a bunch of athletes al Robin said Tyree Jackson
So just catching up with a lot of our dudes business friends, and I'll be very honest with you this
Yeah
there's a lot of people I know about or have relationship watch me just to say a lot like the one of the reasons I've
Done. Well on social media is because social media is about people I love people. I like people
I feel like there's so much happiness and opportunity in abundance in the world that watching other people shine and win
I don't feel like that's coming out that feel is the coming of what I'm a man
The one you gave the rockefellers
Bro, can you check can I get them to do you like they're following section about their rockefeller? Okay you over hit back
I'ma, see you
I'll be with you in a minute
It's just that right like that's happening because people are said like when walk is winning. I'm not like a walkers women
I'm not when I'm dealing him and be like keep shining
Yeah, if there's so much abundance of opportunity
So I'm just trying to get people to look at the world from a different perspective cuz I'm so happy
Yeah, I'm just trying to share it. What am I to do with it going agree with it?
I want to put it out at scale. I'm really good at understanding where the attention is
I was there for search I was there for email. I was there for YouTube. I was there for Twitter
I was I was always
Early because I understand how people consume and I have a good understanding what I think people should be thinking about
Hey speaking of early. Yes any tips on what you think is coming up
You'll preached so it's a very very normal question that I get asked and the answer is I don't know
I'm good at moving fast when I see it. Okay, I'm not gonna sudama's around here
I'm not but I'm unbelievably good at when I see it to go humble and put in the work to establish
my flag in the ground and then I chill and I wait for everybody come and then I go from being stupid or naive or
Wrong or silly to being a genius a day, man
Gary Vee listen more music more fun on the way live from the Superbowl experience with my brother Gary be guaranteed
Do me a favor. Can you say this is Gary Vee and you're listening to the Willie, Moe jr. Show flat out
Yo, it's Gary Vee and you're listening to the Willie mo jr. Show for real
Pretty
Tommy are you mr. Your party don't hat man. Thank you
Um, so rate me it's re gonna come out your party. That makes me happy come through
Tommy about is over Oh can't wait to see you. No pleasure
You lived in the Philly you live in Jersey or
So you should come up the Meadowlands just shoot up 95 and yeah and is he still a big Jets fan, yeah
Yeah, when it went to PS ELLs and up because essentially yeah
I remember he was like number one cuz was before they even started keeping track. He grew up in Queens and
Bronx yeah. Yeah, we had like the two if I actually had aisle and like the next one was the next pricing
If I actually could have like my way of like who was I born it would be like a Bronx Queens kid in like
1953 at the time like 450 43 like yeah
because it was like so like stickball I'll punch you in the face like on our
Work your face off and I'm this entitlement bullshit. You know what I mean a hundred percent
Just see you good to see what's going on with you man. Makes me smile. Thanks. Let me know if I can help
Yeah. Yeah, I'm gonna get you on I mean, you know, we always had you on it was so close, right?
Anytime banks keep doing God, you know when somebody cares, uh
Find me Paul I need him
What's up?
I'm just going crazy. Well, they made me talk about the Browns 86 just like
Thank you guys it's very nice, thank you guys. Yeah. Thank you for having us
We will oh how you have it right? No my late my
Let's go what are we going?
Thanks guys, thank you. Yeah be good
We are
No
It's like Chanel. Oh, yeah, that's awesome a view to real pleasure. Yeah. I've been I've built everything on on your vitamin
So I appreciate everything
Looking forward to breath. We'll see you there
um
Okay, one more Tigers. Yeah, we should meet with him. Yeah, so let's go. Let's go this, okay
David will catch on the way back
Yep
Like
Oh have I got it I was like you need to go Gary
Any time you
See me of course, it's crazy. Oh you wanna use my phone you got a phone I can get one
Oh, yeah, that's like man
That's great team yeah. Hey Jamie, what is it but I just said
That's my son. I sent him about three or four years joints last week about just the Millennials in let's go
How are you man you go good-looking taller than gene pop you married up boy
Everything be good. I'm really alright. Yeah, it's good to see you again
Be good keep listen boy. All right, let's go see letter et. Oh this way
Good to see man. Thank you. Well
Yeah, we're gonna be there we'll see there anyway I'm sorry, I know we we have something late like we have a real legit thing
Okay, see letter you
Thank you, thank you for me. What's your name today, Derek Derek
Thank you, thank you, bro
I execute on my thesis
It's only because I only do what's natural
I'm not doing it for any other reason that I just started. No, I know you know, but it's like interesting like
It's I do it and then I like and then I absorb it submit
Good. Are you doing a manual? I'm amazing. Give me a week. I'm real good. Good to see you
That's why the that's why the marathon vlogs are so good. I've watched it read in the comments people picking up on nuances
Which gives them insight?
South Tower
M4
Am I moving or am I sitting here
Are you sub Pop's?
I'm on this face
T Brock do it do it do a recall of like some early a scary B's where he was like we should pull up my
Twitter picture, it's still me new. I've no I look like a child. I'm a little beer by the way, like that's funny
I saw a picture of
us
When Casey came it was awesome Casey
Like stunning Andy looks like Tyler's kid
Lindsay's eating up a storm zoom in on Lindsay eating a ton. I'm
Kiss is what you do when you're an executive I
Can't wait for one of Lindsey's like high school friends, but like I saw you on I
Will see will see we will see not yet is right. Alex knows the answer every time the answer is not yet
How's it going I
Went to a superhero
My first year out of got like my singing out of college
What was the salad do you have any sense? Can you make it out? Yeah, I'll take one of those. Thank you
What's happening here, okay
It's awesome
Looking good. How's the week been? It's been really good. I got in early yesterday. So I'm kind of still like
Yeah
Looking sharp, brother. Well, yeah coming from work
Walking through Centennial Park in a suit. It's
Like are you an agent?
You know straight up I'm actually curious because of the show but it's so big like and you're a good-looking guy
So there's something that it's almost excuse the variable a little bit but like your fan base
Prop probably is. Like is it 60/40 female like like people that will stop you
Yeah, it's like anything that you like listen this takes a lot
I don't think I don't I don't easily say like this is what everybody should do a
Podcast for free without making any money. Everyone said Carrie. Why don't you make any money?
What I'm doing is I'm thinking about you know, 10 years 2 billion so, you know for me, this is exactly the time
Look what like, what's the world gonna be?
They're gonna look for the most contemporary biggest thought like it's not gonna be complicated. You're so blessed
You have the hard part traditional media leverage
You're young enough your contemporary enough your pop culture because of that phenomenon if you layer this in any shape or form
If you just give me a fucking podcast
Then I can fucking film over two weeks for 10 days in a row and fly all the guests in and bang it out
But then make thousands of pieces of content to fill your fucking social
I
Get it, but I'm I'm I'm I have empathy we've had couple meetings
I'm I'm framing it up to why it's not like hahaha or nice to have I'm framing it up
It was like why this is real fucking money
You'd really hate to like allow me to be sitting with you in six years when the
Second rate person gets the deal because they had a lot more Instagram followers than you and you're gonna sit there me like fuck
my and my whole life's been about saying I told you so
So I really wanted for you
But I have empathy so it doesn't mean to be safe for say this my new hack and we've been talking about is
Podcast a little bit easier a little safer, but you can film it. I just need volume of content
Right. I just need fucking content. That's why when you're like, that's why I said the Tyler. It's like radio Ralph
I was like fucking radio wrong. That's where I'm going cuz there's content here. Excuse me for one second. She laid out
All right still good to see you very good to see ya good ancient ages journey, yeah, I gotta make a quick call to
Where we're supposed to start 15 minutes ago or right now already. Fuck. Yeah. I think we're literally
Look good, man. Thanks, man. Okay, I'm out of season. So um, yeah good. So yeah
My two oldest sons no sure
Nice to meet you, Gary and David David
Carolina thank you brother sick. I said thank you fo you the Green Wave huh? Gerald sole underrated fullback
Yeah
Yeah, I'm gonna try to do this quick phone call, I got a quick phone call, I gotta do something
I gotta take care of I'll be here in five minutes
Uh-oh squad, what's up, everyone?
Thank you so much guys, I'm very flattered. Thank you
Really good. I'm in Atlanta, you know between Vayner sports and vaynermedia. I've got a bunch of good meetings. It's been going
Well, I mean, I hate the Patriots. It's about my fucking heart. So it's like disgusting to see all these people. Uh,
Oh
God, you better be from Boston broke. Then this really matters to you. Like I'll fucking hack it. We will 100% make it happen
My pleasure. All right. I'll see you guys later. Bye bye everyone. Bye guys
Anything else sweet I got to jump to this. I mean we're gonna have a real couple of meetings coming up soon
And you can reach out any time if you want to talk about any this macro stuff
I know Deanna's a
Jacob Salem, we are AJ and I uh sub T pleasure. How are you? Good to meet you man. Hey Janice, my brother AJ
We we rep Geronimo and Josh
Our party, it's my party. Okay you guys coming through are you unless it's out of its real battery on you got it
Yeah, I mean I what was your name again? Nick Robinson? Oh
Yeah
Yeah, man, he has such good things to say about you
Yeah, he made he makes that whole room just dinner but I mean so yeah a lot of young guys. Yeah
Or epitome of
Illinois, yeah, just diligence. Okay that type of stuff lady. How you feeling good?
Good Schumi at
Texas a what you do. Yeah
You often recommend him to be on your team right I literally put up my rankings for next year
You have my number one wide receiver. Is that right?
And sad one and in the rest of us are building up the courage
The only player oh
No, seriously, I'm excited guy man fantasy points in every game this year only play in the NFL
Like whatever Tyreke I'll have a big game whatever
He pisses you off when he's on your fantasy team, thanks for the love
And it's the Vayner sports party Harwood's get notice but it's the manor sports like yeah
Oh
My god we lost our shit yesterday
Here's what?
No, no, we have to go here. The only ten seconds
The only thing I care about now because they Rangers in Yankees won and thus Asia was 11 years younger to me so we didn't
Even get it. We're just basically Yank jets and Knicks fans, and we're in it
There's a rocket there's a reason that kid is the player that he is
It takes both talent and the human you just saw it really matters it really unless you're authentically a dick, right?
Like some guys can be like look you just it takes a lot. It's this man
This is anti-circumcision, this is amazing. This is amazing
Circus this is they're they're they're protesting circumcision. They don't want people to get circumcised
Bro it's even crazier over here
Give it a little more in 70 fucking days
Then you're gonna learn in the next fuckin three and like the last eight years of your life
I really believe that that's our interns
Like literally barely go back to college like and part kids are like from like really like stodgy families
Like where it's like real a big big deal and even they're like don't want to go back
You're gonna fucking love it
Yeah, you've won
yeah, yeah, we'll do though would all do the whole everyone later Talent speaking fuck in and
Big party tonight. Yeah, I mean get ready
Awesome. Can't wait
Let's go. I'm sure I'm sure I can see in their fucking faces. I already knew that you got you one. Yeah you won
I don't know you were supposed to be but you know, that's all that time in fucking one weird place in Connecticut
You must have must have said some charming shit
Yeah, I get it
It's great to see you for the love you I can't wait this might be our time. This might be our time
We'll have a bunch of different conversations
Love it
See you guys later
He's a good guy fuck I got it it was great. All right. Let me go bang this out
How are you? I'm Gary. Oh, yeah, such a pleasure sir. How are you? Hi, how are you? Heard a lot about you
It's such a pleasure to meet you
Hello, sir
Yeah now he's a good dude
So what I can tell you though is this
We transition from the radio to the television and it changed our society
we're
Transitioning from the television to this device and it's changing our society and I do believe that the combination of what we're putting together for
individuals understands that transition better than anybody I took myself from a
Owner of a wine store in New Jersey to what?
I am on the back of it and as you can imagine with something that starts off much further along
It feels like the world is the oyster. The difference is you have to reverse engineer the person of what they're willing to do
What they want to do what they're comfortable to do and what their ambitions are
That makes sense to me that you get it, you know, just knowing enough about your it makes it its content and distribution
If you were in the music business in 1963
There was about four disc jockeys that really goddamn mattered and if you could win with them you could win America
this thing
What I understand is its platform's not people. It's taking the power out of those people that used to be in the middle
There's no gatekeepers
The gatekeepers the end consumer. I'm a man. I'm getting I want you to see it you I have goosebumps
I'll tell you why like and these are real goosebumps
Like no, I mean it it is why everybody hates the Internet they don't understand the all the bad stuff right now
It's exposing us. We haven't changed. It's exposing us. This is the purest thing that's ever happened. It eliminates humans from the middle
The artist has the leverage
The artist has to have humility though to respect the audience and that doesn't always come hand in hand
the artists can't use perfection as disguise for insecurity the artist can't
Arbitrarily because what they feel decide what's right, they have to lean into the end consumer. That is very different
It is my humility and knowing that they're always right. I have hypothesis
but they're always right and
Here and here's the best part on your terms
You're the production company. Nobody felt like you're doing a Barbara Walters interview where you have no idea where it's gonna come from
But what's so remarkable about?
Willing to share that's one thing. I actually don't think that's the case
I think it's about having control about telling the narrative the way you want to tell it
Directly
the end so like I think people are confused on how it's played out and I think people are even more confused and I'm watching
society right now
Demonize social media because we don't like what we're saying on their social. It's us brother. It's us
Facebook did it make you write it you wrote it on Facebook. So what what I see the counter to that which is
This is going to be an amazing era this next generation
Next 20 30 40 years
I can't see past that it's my guess for
The artist and that makes me happy because the artist deserves it
in the last 70 years a lot of people in between the artists in the audience have figured out how to make a
disproportionate amount of money room
Well, we appreciate your time, it was very nice to meet you very nice to meet you such a pleasure sir. Yeah
I'll see you there. Okay. Love you
It was a real pleasure. Oh
You know what? I've had that said to me before yeah at one point
I was getting that a lot for some reason your inspire me. Thank you. Thank you. Nice to meet you. Take care everyone
Take care. Thank you
I
Wanted us to do
Good Wow the original concept with your word my word. There's like even dead will connect back home
Ready, what's going on? Thank you. What's going on now?
Manor kids radio show what? Yeah fix out. Nope
Lose yourself that's fucking amazing there
That's a neat
Thank you. Very inspirational. Thank you. What's your name? Ben Ben. Nice to meet you. Thank you
Bang
The key to success giving zero fucks
Horse the problem so you work with my guy
Thank you
Thank you. I appreciate that. My guy mine you worked with Sebastian Oh Jack, which boss and Rosco. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah
Also my whole company follows you and thank you talks about you a lot. Thank you, bro. Take care changes. I'll try brother
Money
I gotta piss my pants off right there
Do you give my credential? Oh I've got mine, thank you. Thank you
Man
I'm in the game
This is I'm in the full game. I've it's not even like flirting anymore. It's like what up, my man you good?
Nice to meet you
What's your name? Hey
That was funny timing like just so in it like it's not like two years ago. Where was like at nuance
Yeah, can't wait we'll come by please come please got me to be quick please come
Yes, of course, sorry about that it was nice it's good to see you guys yeah for sure yeah looking forward to it
How are you? Um know what else is great is um, I
Like being out and about because people get to see of a nice person
Poor heart in micro moment. Yeah, but I'm good at micro boats. I know
No more and more unfortunately
We're here for I'm gonna be exhausted, I mean I put out a lot of energy already, you know, do you
And might I might
Maybe maybe
7c. Yeah, I could tell you you might get a quick picture
She you wanted to one of the cool entrepreneurs out there Mike. Thank you, bro. Shit. Oh you you know who you are
You're how I found out about gonna
I'm gonna Lana artist
I'm gonna Lana artist and I cook with these guys. Yeah
Yeah
That's an incredible clip that's an incredible
Sign them all Jamal sign them all Jamal
Sign them all baby sign every one of them every one of them make them all fans
every one of them
You guys are gonna make money on that Hall of Fame signature right there. That's good
For sure
Fucking figure it out
Thanks, brother I enjoy you Thank You Somali on everything thank you. Thank you so much
It's from 9:00 to 2:00 a.m. We'll probably get good around 11:00
I'm gonna I'm gonna stop doing tables in a minute make them one. Just Robby's come. I mean a bunch of just fuckin
Yeah, I haven't seen them all. So let's do it
later
I'll see you later, bro. I
Thought I watched you on a Breakfast Club and just listen to your inspiration
Hi, how are you?
How you push that if you really want to go for new you should go for it don't bullshit
it's true and just like cuz that's what's been my focus that she had quit my job, and I've just been
How's it go amazing? I'm a consultant now working myself for Microsoft for you. So just you're so so inspired
Thank you so much. What's your name? Jihad? Jihad. Yes, so nice to meet you. Yeah
Yeah, of course
Amazing take care. Nice meeting you. See you bro. Thanks for watching brother
All these kids housed in a fucking love it. Let's see that's the right table. That's my table too. Let's go
Please that's awesome. I think I think that's like Syracuse broadcasting
Most recently, right
Yeah, I need sugar though, so I was like nom out like if JLo asked maybe I'd consider it but hey rod
I was like get me out of here
Yes
By the way before he leaves just seeing ayan like growing up in Jersey
Yeah, but he was also on an overnight on the fan when you guys were when you guys were more like three and four years
Old when I used to come back from like high school and college parties at like 1:30 in the morning. That's the fucking voice
I was listening to so I loved it
And Gary one thing that I like that you push across a lot yes
We could pursue something such
So for me for you guys today on this day
I would say to not pander to the fan or to barstool or to bleach a report like you don't need what I am needed
I am needed the fan to pick him and
You don't so what I would say is go direct to consumer build your own thing
The end like it's just incredibly
Unbelievable like I would I wish I had what you guys have
like you have a world now where if you're good enough and you do it on Spotify and SoundCloud and YouTube and Instagram and like
You just are it? Like I saw you that you had the a mock draft up. I'm on your tab
Just now if you tomorrow do a mock draft and make a lot of noise on social about it and then that mock draft hits
31 out of 32, which is impossible
I mean I know enough about the mock drafts, but but just play with me here you understand your careers now on
It's you and the end consumer
It's you and the guys and girls that want to listen to the things you talk about and nobody's in the middle
mike, Francesa had an audition
It's
Somebody thought he was enough to give him the at-bat
You never have to live through that
If you don't choose to too many youngsters
Still look at the old path and put on a pedestal and like I'm gonna go to Syria
So West would wanna bark and even new stuff right bar stool didn't it? Huh? My advice to you is do what I did
I didn't go to entrepreneur magazine. I didn't have CNBC to put me on I went direct to the consumer
One thing that I like about you is that you're very confident in being yourself and
Understanding the fact that some people might not like you but you're gonna do it anyway
You know, have you kind of come across a fool in your own style and sure what skills are present
Well, there's two things on that, right?
first of all
I know I'm a nice person and like I get I curse and I could be like Jersey and I
Understand and like it could come off as cocky. I understand, but I know in the end I'll win
Like if you do the right things you win I said to you that I would do this. I was freakin 30 minutes away
We got 37 things that are SuperDuper important and Tyler's like we gotta go do it. I'm like, let's go
you're either a nice person or you're not
So to me as you can imagine
It's not worry seven for me to come off wrong at first because it only means that in nine years
I'll have that moment with them when they come through my key
Oh, I didn't really like you at first but I'm with you now, you know, uh-huh
and then also you can't control everything like I don't like Tom Brady I
Would highly be stunned if he gave a crap, right, but it's very real
I don't like him like so, you know that's circumstances
Right if he was the Packers quote if he was just the Packers quarterback and done all this I'd be more okay with him
But I'm a Jets fan so it's a totally different narrative one of my favorite things about
Growing your brand strategy. Yeah, that's Instagram
Whatever it is the dollar 80 say yes be strategy. I'm a big fan of that. Thank you. Have you been trying it?
I've been trying it. I wouldn't say I'm up to that dollar and 80 cent level to be consistent
Have you had anything good happen yet with it
Because you know a lot of people used to be big on that
Garbage garbage. Yeah, I think I've heard this with you in terms of
anything
No, I'm just I'm glad you brought it up because everybody just like first of all having your self-esteem wrapped up with how many followers
You have and instagrams already a problem. Let's start with that comma and then what you're gonna gain me
You're just gonna follow a bunch of people and then when they felt like half of them follow you back because they take a look
And then you unfollow like your scam artist like your manipulator. That's not what it's about
So, I don't know. I just don't like it
Where is what I told you the dollar eight is strategy for anybody listening go to 90 counts
Leave your two sets right adds up to a dollar eighty
You can go to every sports account see what they said about the KP trade
Read what the caption is and leave a thoughtful point of view and be like yo
but I think they're gonna cut the Andre like, you know, like
That's real. That's work. I know I don't want guy you see to that nearly every square
Social posts Dennis Rodman just comments. Literally nothing. He would lose Commons his name. He's over there
I'm sorry something that he failed to mention is aspiring
Or be trying to rep let's go bronies personal thing releasing videos
I mean, I think I mean look you've seen what I think you know
I've had a lot of emerging hot artists come through and I tell them all the same thing man
I'm like, it's no different sportscaster. I think it's like cut out music on on soundcloud
DM people, don't be like, oh you want to use my music in your vlog like like it's its content and its distribution
Right if you were remarkable
right, if you if you were John Madden and you were great at it and you got lucky enough that somebody chose you and put
You on Fox or see me like you you won Tony Romo
Got great exposure. I was dead when they announced Romo. It's funny. I see him in the corner. I love Phil Simms. I loved
The way film Sims added to those games like he was my favorite Lampley and Sims Jets Patriots
That was Nirvana for me. So I was cynical about the Tony Romo thing until he like became a meme right? He killed it
So like it's exposure and being good at it the internet
Let's everybody have exposure no middleman, but now you got to be good. I
Am how to get lucky to get the app back and how to be good
You guys have to be better than everybody at Syracuse at home in their room or anywhere else in the world
You understand? I love that that feels like Mary
Gary Vaynerchuk and Gary something you mentioned in
Or podcast once
Especially with Venus what athletes career
Yes second, why is that your vision?
Um because it's my competitive advantage and it's a nice thing to do
You know
I feel like I don't know like like it's a it would be really nice that like any kid that signed Tyree
Jackson or Josh Jackson. These guys are gonna better lives because the cyma greater sports. I
Don't know what else to tell you. I genuinely believe that I believe there's very nice people an athlete
I think Miu Leggett is a beast of an agent
I think there's great people out there and I just think I'm a better you I don't know I maybe I'm wrong
Maybe it's ego. But I know I'm gonna really care and not about money and
I know it's my advantage. I want Vayner sports to be the number one sports firm at a Super Bowl in 23 years from now
How do I do that?
Well all the kids that came through and said I made more money from 37 to 52 or dipper
Gary helped me through my divorce or he put my kid on
That's gonna matter
That's why
We got to talk some Jets, yeah
I'd be real mad at you guys wouldn't get to go to youtube you guys by the way on the record
I think this NFL Draft is gonna be soft
Historically saw last year as you think was great. Yes quarterback. Yes
Dude I mean you just ran to the corner like
Donald's the first quarterback I've had since Chad Pennington that I thought could be the guy and like, you know
And then he and then he throws up. Do you know what I
Was in a coma his first NFL pass I was like
atonic, I
Couldn't wrap my head around what I just saw. I didn't even by the way you'll love this on the road
I try to stay chill cuz I don't wanna get kicked out, right?
Cuz I don't miss plays
So I'm already pretty passive on the road until the end whenever the only reason we did that is cuz out every lion fan left
So we could get a little, you know crunk in there. I'm sitting there. I didn't even move literally
Let me just show you I know this rate like I'm gonna show you physically what happened. Here's the pass pass intercepted touchdown
I didn't move
Didn't even move
Yeah, it was like, you know, it's funny we have our things whatever like fine like there's a lot of bad franchise
I was just in a coma
Like you couldn't make it up
his first passes a pick six and then he goes on to play really nice the solid compose pick themself up from like you get
Knocked down in the first round. You win a fight. You're a dog, you know what I mean?
Like I like boxing a lot. You're a dog like oh something's mental. That's a different mental thing. So,
Yeah, man, I'm super fired up about him. But yes, I do think next year's first
I also think throwing James at Denzel Ward. Like I think there's some real half c'est quand c'est quand chubb
I'm very big on lashings wrap. Like I'm not very big on this year's collective draft
Game is to one day. Yes
And it's they've been so bad for our entire life but it's your passion that makes him so terrific
Yeah, I'm wanted by the Jets and honestly, I want to try to buy the Jets more than anything like to me
The the ambition to buy the Jets is like the intoxicating part of this
Like it's fun to you'd like I wake up every morning like like I'm fire
like squeezing like
Like toads already last night
Super Ball, I'm old
now that like you youngsters can do it like gotta get up like the breakfast meeting looks like
the draftkings see ol I gotta get up like
You know like but I'm on fire even though I'm old and tired and like, you know
And so it's good man the having a great ambition and by the way look
It's really morphed when I was in second grade when I decided I didn't even know why I said it
Maybe because I started realizing I was gonna be able to play for them
but
Now it's like my ambition to buy the Jets
My ambition that my journey and my efforts doing it the right way will inspire other people
There's a lot that started starting to get heavy and good and awesome and exciting
At verse city, you know wasn't born in America we didn't have much
You know, I wasn't tall like I got bad grades like, you know, like everything in my life was you suck you suck you suck
Ship on shoulder. I'll show them
Like, you know, definitely that that's definitely a driver not having money
I want a Nintendo mom like everybody cool go get it crap. I better sell my baseball cards, you know what I mean?
like, you know like in you know like
Listen, there's a reason that a lot of affluent kids struggle to be alphas when you're fed. You're not hungry
It's good, right
Most viral videos that I seen
Suggestions about why you shouldn't go to college. Hmm. You think we're making a mistake in going to college right now?
No, I don't. I think it's very circumstantial
I think if you're going to college and collecting debt right now
and there's not a job on the other side of it that
You might be making a mistake
like if one of the four of you have 89 thousand dollars in debt at the end of this and your plan was this will
Put me on though and I'll pay it off
the interests are gonna pay on that and the jobs that I actually think they're gonna be available to you based on the reality of
What college offers versus the reality of job things?
Could be a challenge could be so when I talk about it. Talk about it in nuances, right?
but like there was kid yesterday who comes from like an alcoholic, you know, dad and a gambling mom and he's like
He's a hood situation and he's wants to go to college. I'm like, uh, he's not a good student
He's gonna go like some bunk school
like collect massive debt
Walk into a tough environment, you know what I mean? So, you know, where do you guys all going?
Right. So like what I don't know is what Fordham's current state a brand of what you guys do and how
Serious and NBC looks at it if you want to get a job
I also started this session by telling you to go direct to consumer
So I don't even want you to go and work at freakin CBS Sports
You know, so think about where I'm at, right?
I don't want you to go to CBS Sports if god forbid in my
Framework of this conversation you're taking on a hundo in debt to hope that the Fordham brand gets you a job at NBC
Not my strategy
Could be wrong could be right and then everybody goes through what about like we grew up as men here
We met other people and hooking up and all that like you can do that anywhere
You go backpack through your free and hook up and become a man. Okay, what's the score?
And then the Patriots are gonna win. It's just
but one of my audience who's a big Jets fan says if the Patriots winning means Brady and Belichick
You'll never have to see him again what you go in on
Go in on it. I would do anything
Yeah, but that's not happening. That's not happening and
Brady's playing forty five minimum unless he has a cut at traffic injury
It's you know, it feels like it almost feels like that the whole thing sucks on the flipside be honest with you
I really prefer that Phil and Sam. Excuse me, that bill and Todd stay Tom stay
I would love for the Jets to you know with this regime go into New England and beat them in a playoff game
You know what? I mean a hundred percent like I'm
So I I'm a Jets Knicks guy, right? I know you got to wrap up here, but I got to tell you this
The Knicks in the prime years like like it was amazing and I never got to beat shortest like my guys never beat Jordan
I don't know what it feels
Like I know what it feels like to be Brady in New England in a humongous playoff game that he's referenced multiple times this week
Means it's steal father said he knows that 2010 team but they beat us 45 to 35 weeks earlier
So, you know what that felt like for me man. I'm gonna just say it on the record
It's the best day of my life. I have two children. I have a good life
I'm married the single best day of my life was beating the Patriots in that playoff game in January 2011 in 10,000 2010 season
Yes, yes, this is why I fear him so much I know him he's a six rounder like he one he's out
I mean no, but like but there's a lot of stuff. Let's put it this way
I understand a lot about him and
Where he bothers me even more than let's say Jordan is I know who Jordan is off the court. I don't aspire for that
But Tom's a good dude hate it
I may not like it but there's a lot of good there and none of these are competitor and like that six round chip
You can't replicate that stuff voice. You can't replicate that stuff, man
Listen looking at the four of you. If I could tell you anything find adversity. Don't run away from it
Everybody runs away from it now because they don't like the judgement of ELLs ELLs are the foundation ELLs are the foundation
See your Vader sports
With me I'm Bob. You see I'm a better sports director for these guys. That's awesome real pleasure
Good promising future especially keep pushing
Merkle expired to me talk to you soon. Nice thing, sir
Sports director of a decent people here in Atlanta. Let's obviously men appreciate the hustle in the game. Thank you. Very crying
Everybody deserve everything coming away. So I appreciate that Atlanta street you are it really has much love. Thanks for saying that
Yeah, of course I've been going I'll keep you safe on the other side of this way
You inspire me man, I thank you. Thank you so much. Yes
Rise yes, just curious if you'd be willing to do our partners or no
Time, what do we got how much time two minutes one minute zero minutes?
We were gonna do the call on two minutes the day I got to that call. Yeah
Okay, let me let me I will come over if I can all right, thank you let's just call yeah, so
Yeah for sure
There's made this camera look even better. Oh that thing is crazy
I do these silly car wrapping videos. Yes. If at any point, I thought that there was some kind of crossover
Yeah, who would be the best person to just like this? You got right here. Let's go right here. Okay, Tyler
Loved it. That's awesome. You see ya man. Do you me? Oh, yeah me I'll see it. Okay, cool. Fine. Let's go. Yes
How are you yeah, yeah, it's great. I was in the back room you had boxes all over you said Brad
This is the week one of my wallet. Yeah. I'm so very proud of you. Hey
Any time since trains any time
I need to get my lights up brother. Let's go Brad when they see me with you
That's what's up. Yeah, they're gonna know I'm talking one get to the bag. Let's go and get one more. All right
Let's get out of the bag
Listen, you help baby one love Thank You Brad. All right
Yeah, of course what back to the house shed the serious that we were
Okay
Just like and and I just want to know how many tables you know, have we sold
I know we'll probably sell something during the time. I want to make sure there's a jet table
I want to make sure there's a table for me
You know, like let multiple tables for me so I don't feel crunched. So I guess that's where I'm at. Does that make sense?
Wow listen I watch his thing
Oh I get it I get it I get it
Yeah, I want I want to listen
I want to get one of the biggest thing that I think is running through my mind is what?
The ratio of male females gonna be because if it's even which I don't think it's gonna be at this point
But if it the more even it gets the more likely people gonna stay late
Got it. Okay, cool
Sounds good. I'm good. Nope. I'm good. Thanks
Table 13 for the Jets
See the different spots where I
Get the bands
Oh
Jake has become our show last year when I was on Long Island. How are you?
So I'm now with SP nation radio. I do a national show
So I don't I just want to talk just with you for a moment here
Sure, because uh I had our guy tomorrow Adams on
Yep, and you will appreciate this because you are actually a real fan, which is what I respect the hell out of here
so my dad made me a Jeff and
Jamal came on. Yep, you got to see this
He's a great kid amazing. I love Jamal today. Hello. We had like the so like with it last year
We had to beg you to come on when you're in between appearance to say like we had like the Backstreet Boys book they did
Five interviews. We had Wilson. Come on spit this morning, man
Come on last year everyone
You know is so funny house big of a social media star yard
Because the out of all the pictures we posted the fact that we had you for like the four minutes
We talked to Jansen whenever that was like the coolest thing that came up. We got another picture together. Of course, it's awesome here
I'll take a picture y'all
Time moving. Alright, let's go. Let's get Bobby
She's
Not bad, right. I don't I don't do a show I
a company a marketing company in a sports representation business
Yeah might well like contract like Jerry Maguire and I started something called Vayner sports
Yeah, our last names Boehner Chuck and we represent Leonard Williams. Alan Robinson, Josh Jackson
She drew a lot of athletes only athletes like like Jerry Maguire like football actually just footballs
It's only a three year old company. We just started it
and then I do I have a marketing company called vaynermedia which works with Budweiser and Chase Bank and like
Advertised like a classic advertising agency, but very new you get like we'll make it happen
We'll do it
Welcome
Nope we have a big competing famous sports party. Yeah. Yep
For essentials, what do you got? I got a list see email me. How are you?
You're welcome so much nice to meet you I
Met you in Minneapolis, how are you gonna see you'll see as well a DJ so then DJ for NFL, that's awesome
Off the man always I love hearing yourself instinct you bro. Thank you so much. Thank you
So I've been eating shit, but I seasoned it with Larry's
Talk to everybody let's go. Hey, hey, I'm gonna tell it's real simple. You got one fucking life do something
Please fuck which waiting for for who nobody's listening to complaining anyway do something
You already best
Man great day. Thank you
Seriously, nobody listens to your fucking complaining
fuck
Like nobody gives a fuck. They got their own problems. Do you understand?
You don't know what people's problems are you think they don't have problems that's why many of you can sell
You all we sit up people you want something that sales people aren't selling
Whoo
She comes a bar
You got 20 minute ride to your hotel gara. Don't give a fuck about the old guard. It's old for a reason. I
Was good man, how are you? Thank you so much man
Yeah, you didn't go to India Nelly shit your pants
Yes, I have laid out here whole day to see you buddy you made it happen brother good to see you man
See, what's your name? Marcus Marcus. Nice to meet you. I'm so I just want to tell you just very quick please 30 seconds
I used to play victim all the time. Hey buddy safety right here at kainalu
I useful if it's him all the time make excuses blame my privilege for him everything. Yes, then I heard you I didn't like you
Anybody who starts with a lot of excuses because I'm bad to love you so much at first no
but then I kept listening why I
Think mainly because they knew that you was right. I just didn't like to hear it. I understand
So I kept listening kept listening and I've listened to you for five years. Now. You've completely changed my life
I don't like to ask that you just to let you know you've changed your life
Thank you, but I just had a little assist that makes me so happy bro. I saw your photo II a hundred percent
D-roc special
Thank circuit to me thank you for saying that my name's a lot too much thank you. Yes
all right every minute with uh with bonding and um
Like a low in the South by how much yeah. Yeah, how you don't look good to see Matt. Good to see you. Well
Hey
Brian alright, Brian Brian nice to meet you. How are you guys doing good. Great to see you. Good to see you man
You do love it. Yeah, I
Just talked to me yesterday. It's awesome. Stay. Well. Take care guys
Thank you
Honestly, thank you that meant a lot to me man. That came real pure I
Appreciate it. Keep doing it
Keep doing it. Great to meet you. Great to meet you, too
Where we go? Oh, sorry. What does everything? Oh, it's a tree man. Yes. I got it
Yeah, yeah
Gary yeah, what up it up. What up, baby?
Thank you, brother. I appreciate to the city. Thank you. My man. Thank you, bro. Are you appreciate I'm real good. Thank you
Yo, you could have been a tree. I've been trying to tell people you could have been a tree and have it told you
Thank you, bro
The trees a fan the trees a fan let's do it. Let's do it
Do you rock photo
Boom such a pleasure
Take care of him over yelled at all
She knows she's fucking doing her job exactly. You got a baby
I'm so glad that wasn't me
The trees of man, I love your shadow broke the trees
You could have been a real I need an x-ray I'm gonna be like you could have been a tree
That was a fan
Yeah, you got a love life. You've got a bit of tree. That was a fan
I'm gonna win a fucking Super Bowl and I'm gonna do it again
And again, do you understand how fun? This is gonna be to play in a Jumbotron after I fucking do it?
I've really been trying to tell him
No matter what
All I do is all I do is all I do is win win win no matter what did I hear that somewhere subconsciously
What hello, how are you
All I do is win win
So I thought somebody for closet dirt. All I do is Vallon
When when when no matter what?
Yes
Thank you, I love all your videos so I actually
just
Got a job with Google
And like I just kind of everything like listening to the stuff that you've been saying on Instagram, I love following you, too
So thank you and like working hard is something that I keep reaching
Definitely listen to it though. Thank you so much. Thanks for saying hi. Yeah Coryell pleasure. Take care all
I do is win when you enjoy matter. What all I do this win-win window
Yo
Of course I know I
What's your name Darrien Darrien nice nice to meet you, oh
Man, I just like keep you up on Instagram or snap. That's like Oh Gary you right down the street from me. I
Throw
Thanks, man, appreciate it
That's my favorite the god
Suffocating that bullshit suffocating y'all bullshit, you know
Gary guy, that's me
Thank you, thank you thank
You I think what are you doing here just business
Kill yourself ready
You might have started you may start out hating me yeah, you may start out hating me but
You may start it you may start out hating me dot dot dot but
It's cuz I'm suffocating your bullshit
No, no just fuck that's it I'll take care of the copy I do the copy
All I do is win we win no matter what Oh,
What's up office fucking day
Yeah
What up baby I
Heard me I'm excited
How you been man how you feeling fam I
Can't wait to see you ready for tonight that place is gonna be completely out of control
Completely, yeah, what up?
What up when you guys coming through
All right bad, I'll see you there soon I can't wait man we got you set up properly
Where's your head at where's your head at anything I can help you with?
I need you think you thinking about mindset marketing anything like that
Can't wait see ya. Love you bet
I would have
You're gonna press my boy, I can't be Adams - he's a good kid. He's good kids
Coming ok, so I decided to do more value on my Instagram like you said I wanted to know if
Really quick with every Sunday. I felt like motivation
I just tell everybody to be happy where they are and I care what anybody else answer gamers
account with my phone I
Want to go face going on? Oh, yeah
Go listen, do not care what anybody has to say about you
Tell them Gary because it's a truth because I driven on somebody else's fucking you're never gonna win that way either which doesn't work
You're trying to impress people. You don't even fucking like
All about uncensored right one life fucking living the only fate you have it's best
I don't share beautiful living out here like they're coming back
Hi, how are you?
Nice to meet you, thank you coming, isn't it? Say hi and grab a photo for
What's up
Everybody bullshitting out here like they're coming back. You got one fucking life living
I really appreciate thank you who's got the camera way that afraid
Thank you
We got Roger, how are you
That's how it is with you, we'll hold it
Sorry about that a video. Okay ready
Okay, guys are you
Coming I'm so glad you're here
Frank this is one of my best friends. I made from the school. My kids look moose went to college with me
This is my god. We want real stories. Yeah, this guy's got him
Sister line, how are you?
We're gonna go yeah go post op and I'm gonna make a cocktail
You a few years back and after you I took all your advice I crushed it man crushing it
That makes me happy from I appreciate all your time
How are you
Maynard's hood and explosions. Thank you for coming from and quality six Wine Library TV back in the day
Thank you, bro. Pleasure to meet you quick. Let's do it
Cheers brother, bro. Thank you
How are you madam? Are you good to see you? We were very much with mr
Wolf actually called in recently and talking about business and humor like coffee empathy wines like a guitar. Thank you
Thank you. Enjoy. It my Jets my jet fucking appreciate taking photo. I gotta say somebody
So good to see you brother, how are you
Congratulations to both of you. Thanks. You got triple CI CEO party. Now who's got the camera one thing photo? Yeah. I got it
- congratulations servant they throw a real pretty man that really like when we get the top any time
We play each other next year. Here's I do cuz I got your can hope where I think
Jackson I think Jackson I think Jackson
Wait to tear is Lee goes up there
This guy
I run a tech company called. Whoo. We build wearable technology
We're partners with all the players in NFL awesome tow. And there's maybe something to do together. Hitomi work my brother he thinks
What?
Thank you for coming you guys ringing yes
Yeah, we're gonna go maybe outside of my keys, all right cool fuck the mic they're cool
Thanks, brother thanks for coming I'll reach out to AJ
Yeah, HAF fader sports adventurous a jack because a lot of the athletes you represent. We probably work with Tom
Woo and we're all about improving performance recovery sleep Sossamon. Hey, thank you for tunngle. Yeah. Thanks for having me
Hope you guys enjoy
You made it brother some good games activated let's go
I realize how thick it's moving a ha ha. There you go. Oh, there we go
Life is good boys one life baby pay living even at my age, but keep doing
You know, that's my fucking foundation boy, that's my fucking foundation yo, thanks for coming. All right. Thank you probably
Super and I'm three years. I've been to like three regime change in yet every time just took over so
Shit man
You know my mic boy
You rock if there's some way to get him in my voice connected today I
Really want him to know I have a feeling. I'll be real good
So much
But I never been nervous around Obama
It's video this video
Oh, we're doing mmediately one opposite top yo
And you did it did it
Oh, Gary
Redoing that again this year. I want to keep it in to England every weekend what kind of jets ha dicho are really the best
Impression
Alexia fucking Alexa listenin to you
I want to bring New York
It's so good to see you Thank You Man listen boys and all the generation ivy
Was like the best advice to women artists first times Madeira not
What's the best advice when the artist first sounds the big deal to realize the work just begun
people fucking celebrate a deal like it's something
Celebrating a deal is fucking stupid. That's like celebrating at halftime. You haven't done shit if you sign a deal motherfucker, you heard
You made it proudly at the show by the way I had to beat you man, what's up, right?
Motivational and it's got did a swear from the fucking heart and from the fucking dome with your fucking life
I'm telling you. We ain't going to it we doing it
a little bit
Bahamut over 100 saying so nice, you know now would it
Research is important to Tyler. Yeah, man of appreciation. Thank you, brother. Thank you here
Let me get
Pleasant
So far we pass inside, oh, thank you
Myself you happy man already don't fuck with you. So so happy you don't even know. No, it's a bigger than that
Oh you rock pretty right this fucking guy the best that fucking did it you heard the best up fucking did it
I'm serious. No, I know we can deliver here there anything you need in perpetuity mixed in 50 years
Anything about 100 percent there man, you brought me a lot of fucking joy
awesome
Thank you coming down there great booty for you, are you set up inside you want me to care just walk there
Be some shit like this happens very much Dave
But that was the fucking best that's my fucking it's Darrelle Revis
Fucking do you want to talk about the importance of the process really quickly?
No, they're only is the process you already know some diamonds of success you fucking balls
You just right here. First, you fucking live the process we fucking lost. Absolutely Garrett
Please forward
Stop listening to fucking people's opinions
Everybody's living for somebody else's life
Your fucking life when you're 25, you got another 75 fucking years. Slow it down patience patience boy
Thank you so much. You're welcome and appreciate you guys hanging around
He looks good by the guys I'll lose the jacket. Yeah you better
Coming here
In the middle, yeah
Page six light baby. Let's go page 6 line. You got a brother
Now our poison are you I mean like I need to like have much
Family I love this guy. I love this guy. I need to know your 20 year ESPN stories. That's why I
Want real shit. There's a lot real shit. I don't I
want the real champ York you and your wife will go to the doctor and we were like
A fucking message for your mother fucker zero your fucking messages for you
Like this my big rock give you one of those right here baby the Cougar go
I know you're sick of seeing me man
What's one piece? What's the best thing that you can give to the people right now?
Optimism perspective reality like everybody needs a little something different the truth
That's the fuckin fuckin truth the truth
He shave his head whose shaving his head
So and then the other ones I have in my pocket are just to get it to the table area, okay
I want to go see let's go. It's my gun. I'm ready. Thank you so much
- shout out the best entrepreneurs and tower hand. How are you? Hold on. Yeah, cuz that's confident
No big fucking love
The powered hands what up? Let's go. Let's go Ashley. You're welcome. Thank you. Enjoy
Fully converted motherfucker remember course might happen didn't even get to see you. This party is awesome
And I told your brother you guys go down
I'd love to do that
Let's get me out of here cuz I gotta go soon
I'm taking these two
Danny what I would say. Thanks for having us on
What's up the tablespace
I think I hit that shit
Okay
Oh
Yeah
Quite a jump ball
Jariyama Getty Images
Right
Wait to see grizzly from time
Girl this is Delta girl
I got you
Let's go
Oh
No, you guys let me get you guys to let me go let me tell you guys up let's go
Who's in your crew? Let's go. I need that mint scent table 13
Yeah -
You know I'm saying one of my favorite artists T grizzly let's go
Okay, maybe I need to get rowdy at least thing you can work your horn he got some good
Let's go hey V I
Love you hate anybody rock would be online you I appreciate
Your support I want y'all know y'all support keeping these like me off the streets. I appreciate this city
Once again, give it up for motherfuckin secrecy. What's
Fuckin killed it
Twitter Instagram snap. I was doing everything
Make sure your drinks of water
Nobody don't know that keys Elsa me. Oh, so pretty ready
I'm not swayed
Well something
Where
These courses shit
I guess you know I'm sitting so I know if I got lamb I'll
Fuckin school for a patient's up in this bitch, but up, it's time. I guess we've got detective patrons out. Let us say aye
Fuck dick what make some fucking noise